le lac le plus vieux du monde les lacs
n'ont généralement pas plus de quinze
mille ans le baïkal à plus de 25
millions d'années
ici vivent des esprits et des divinités
bouddhiste
[Musique]
l'eau pure et transparente du lac aide
les scientifiques à résoudre des
mystères de l'univers
je vois le baïkal comme un ensemble
cohérent je ne savais pas à quoi
m'attendre ici ce n'est pas que je
découvre quelque chose de nouveau ici je
m'imprègne simplement de tout ce qu'il y
a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui pousse tout simplement un
apnéiste à vouloir touchées les abymes
le but ultime c'est pas forcément de
gagner des médailles watch au podium
c'est d'arriver à gérer ses émotions
dans un certaine nombre et c'est un
univers qui nous permet justement
d'aller encore plus loin dans cet état
d'introspection et de travail sur le
corps et aussi sur l'esprit plus on va
être dans l'instant présent et on va
être capable de gérer ce qu'on en a à
faire est concentré sur ce que l'on fait
c'est ta confiance et la capacité à
vivre l'instant présent à être connectés
que sur ce qui se passe sur les sons sur
le toucher sur le ressenti et ça nous
pousse dans ses retranchements à changer
des choses dans nos propres vies
en dehors de la cne
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités en plateau et nos
reporters sur le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce mardi
elle le gouvernement face à deux motions
censure de la droite et de la gauche
sont débattus à l'assemblée nationale ce
soir alors que les opposants à la
réforme était dans la rue aujourd'hui
également ils étaient vingt mille à
paris selon les syndicats la crise
coronavirus emmanuel macron qui évoque
une phase qui va durer des semaines et
sans doute des mois
quatrièmement recensés en france
aujourd'hui sur 212 car a confirmé dans
l'hexagone
le président annonce la réquisition des
stocks et de la production de masques de
protection
un conseil de défense aura lieu un
mercredi lieu se dit au côté de la grèce
et promet toute l'aide nécessaire les
dirigeants européens sont à la frontière
gréco turque où des milliers de migrants
affluent depuis que chez hyper doan a
ouvert les portes pour faire pression
sur les occidentaux dans le dossier
syrien
les pays membres de l'ue eux viennent de
donner leur accord pour une intervention
rapide de frontex l'agencé européenne de
contrôle des frontières aux etats unis
c'est le grand jour pour les cinq
candidats de la primaire démocrate celui
du super tuesday 14 états vont voter en
même temps un moment clé dans le
calendrier électoral pour désigner celui
ou celle qui devra affronter donald
trump dans la course à la maison blanche
[Musique]
le recours par le gouvernement aux 49 3
ravit donc la protestation en france
l'assemblée nationale se penche ce soir
sur les deux motions de censure déposée
par l'opposition de droite et de gauche
l'issue reste incertaine les députés
sont toujours sous le choc
vis à vis de cette décision et écouté le
débat n'est pas terminé
le débat va se poursuivre au sénat puis
évidemment en seconde lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
par ailleurs il se poursuit dans une
autre enceinte qui est celle de la
démocratie sociale avec un objectif qui
pour nous était essentiel ce que j'aurai
l'occasion de redire tout à l'heure lors
du débat de motion de censure dans le
cadre de la conférence de financement
nous souhaitons que cette conférence
soit un succès ce que nous voulons c'est
que le gouvernement soit censuré parce
que il est illégitime à faire ce qu'il
fait moi je veux vous dire mon sentiment
c'est que je pense que plus profondément
on est devant une crise de la vème
république
c'est je pense que là on est au bout
d'un régime qui dysfonctionnent
profondément et qu'il faut pas
simplement et pauline aimé qu'il faut
changer
c'est pour ça que nous on plaide pour
une sixième république parce que je
crois que il ne faut plus que demain ce
type de recours aux 49 3 pour en fait
que l'exécutif ait le dernier mot sur le
législatif puisse être possible
cc on a en a un pouvoir qui est encore
pétri d'un héritage monarchique et je
pense que ça va pas du tout l'opposition
parlementaire opposition dans la rue
également les protestataires ont répondu
à l'appel des organisations syndicales
mobilisation cet après midi contre le
recours par le gouvernement aux 49 3
david khalifa a suivi la manifestation
parisienne
la manifestation s'est achevée sur les
coups de 17 heures ici place de la
madeleine et non devant l'assemblée
nationale
initialement comme initialement prévu
les forces de l'ordre ont bloqué l accès
à l'assemblée nationale ce qui fait que
la plupart des manifestants se sont
dispersés assez rapidement en tout cas
un important dispositif de sécurité
avait été mise en place par le préfet
didier lallement qui avait annoncé
mettre tous les moyens matériels et
humains pour éviter tout débordement et
toute violence en marge du cortège des
violences et des débordant qui n'ont
pas eu lieu puisque la manifestation
elle s'est passée de manière pacifique
une mobilisation assez importante en
réponse au gouvernement qui a eu recours
aux 49 3 pour passer ce projet de
réforme des retraites
je vous propose d'écouter esther
benbassa qui était au sein du cortège
cet après midi il ya eu quand même
enfin un glissement vers une démocratie
autoritaire d'un côté là
la violence des interventions policières
le nombre de blessés le la façon d'agir
à l'endroit des gilets jaunes et de
l'autre côté maintenant on se retrouve
avec un texte qui a été quand même et 10
ont bâillonnés avec le 49-3
la députée écologiste souligne le déni
la démocratie c'est ce qu'on a souvent
entendu un durant à cet après midi de la
part et des manifestants qui étaient
nombreux pour répondre à l'attitude je
cite détestable du gouvernement et
d'edouard philippe d'avoir profité du de
l'épidémie du courant navires us pour
pouvoir annoncer ce fameux avec 49,3 en
tout cas elle la mobilisation va se
perdre durée durant tout le mois de mars
notamment le samedi 14 veille des
municipales mais aussi le 31 mars
oula l'intersyndicale et
l'interprofessionnelle appel à une grève
générale afin de bloquer tout le pays
pour pouvoir mettre fin à cette réforme
des retraites et pour pouvoir répondre
aux 49 3 rôles cgt val-de-marne et pour
en parler nous sommes nous avec caroline
mécary avocate et benjamin amar porte
parole cgt val de marne on l'a entendu
d'ailleurs
bonjour moi j'aime à marc bonjour
également caroline mécary merci d'être
avec nous alors les premiers chiffres de
la mobilisation parisienne ils nous
viennent des syndicats exclusivement le
ministère de l'intérieur ne s'est pas
encore exprimé 20000 à paris selon les
syndicats que dit ce chiffre alors on
parle d'une mobilisation plutôt
clairsemé en général dans les dépêches
le 49-3 vraiment ravi veine m
lisa sion selon vous au raja ben ammar
mais je pense que certains commentateurs
ferait bien de revenir dans le monde
réel le 49-3 il date de samedi on est
mardi vous avez il ya un certain nombre
de secteurs d'abord vous faut faire des
déclarations avant de se mettre en grève
c'est ma roue ce qui à certains
éditorialistes qui s'empressent je parle
pas de personnes ont manifesté des
premiers à applaudir quand il ya par
exemple le service minimum donc bien
évidemment quand on est sur une sur une
initiative aussi réactive bas bien sûr
que tout le monde ne pas se mettre en
grève et que encore une fois c'est des
gens qui ne se sont pas mobilisés sans
doute depuis clovis mais qui n'ont
jamais fait grève depuis vercingétorix
mais dans la dans le monde réel du
capitalisme du 21e siècle
oui bien sûr les initiatives elles ont
fatalement moins massive pour autant il
ya quand même effectivement des dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui se sont
mobilisés alors que la prochaine date de
mobilisation c'est celle du 31 mars
donc bien sûr que le 49-3 scandalise et
ils scandalise ceux qui se sont arrangés
pour être en grève et au mali pour
aujourd'hui et bien au delà la question
surtout et c'est celle qui vous
intéresse et qui intéresse tout le monde
est ce que aujourd'hui ces mobilisations
peuvent vraiment pesé sur un
gouvernement qui a l'air complètement
déterminé
à passer en force vermant caroline
mécary l'hermance un gouvernement qui
passe en force après deux ans de pseudo
concertation parce qu'il n'ya en réalité
il n'y en a pas eu
bien qu'il ait été étrillé par le
conseil d'état qui a rendu un avis qui
devrait véritablement que ce projet de
loi n'est ni fait ni à faire une étude
d'impact qui montre que les calculs sont
un sincère etc etc
mais il n'en démord pas il veut si vous
avez vu vous des études d'impact très
précises ah oui alors là ah oui alors la
levée profession non non oui mais
justement là il y en a pas prenez par
exemple c'est comme ça question lorsque
c'est mérité l'étude d'impact est non
seulement un sincère mais elle est
incomplète et lacunaire vous ne
trouverez pas notamment un exemple type
de femmes avec des enfants donc
réellement nous savons que ce
gouvernement est dans une logique qui
est une logique dogmatique
c'est à dire en ligne de mire les
retraites ne doivent pas peser plus de
14% du pib très bien et donc comme dans
la conférence du financement on a appris
que il n'y aurait absolument aucune
possibilité de discuter sur une
éventuelle augmentation de la cotisation
patronale qui va payer ce sont les
travailleurs qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
dans le public ou dans le privé où que
ce soit des travailleurs indépendants
donc dès samedi soir à l'annonce du 49-3
ils viennent des mobilisations
spontanées dans toute la france et en
l'espace de même pas deux jours il a
fallu monter la manifestation
d'aujourd'hui mais y'a pas que les
manifestations qui vont peser
il y à de si je prends simplement les
avocats les avocats qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont utiliser ils vont utiliser les
armes qu'il connaît c'est à dire la
parole et le moutier juliet judiciaire
juridique donc ça va être des actions en
responsabilité contre l'état ça va être
les discussions avec les sénateurs parce
que là le projet de loi certes dont on
connaît pas le contenu quand même hein
on ne connaît pas le contenu
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai sujet donc
il va passer au sénat les sénateurs ils
ont un pouvoir réellement et ensuite au
final on ira peut-être jusque devant fin
même sûr on ira devant le conseil
constitutionnel
mais les batailles elles ne sont perdus
que lorsqu'on cesse de les mener donc
nous sommes debout et nous sommes contre
cette réforme pas que les avocats les
travailleurs les enfin salariés
fonctionnaires sont aussi impactés par
cette vague là bas bon mais d'abord oui
effectivement il faut poser clairement
cette ce cette réalité là le goût
moment à défaut de convaincre puisque
sur la question de la bataille de
l'opinion comme disait raoul volfoni
dans les tontons flagueurs ils se sont
fait exploser façon puzzle
c'est à dire que maintenant plus
personne au sein de sa majorité n'ose
parler de la bataille de l'opinion
ils ont renoncé à cela les sondages sont
très claires deux tiers des français
effectivement sont opposés à la réforme
deux tiers des français exigent un
référendum sur cette réforme et non pas
1 49 3 et donc à défaut de convaincre
cette majorité elle essaye de vaincre
donc elle essaye de voyages français se
on a du mal à comprendre effectivement
cette motivation du gouvernement un
projet politique
enfin alors ils sont l'objet comme ça en
l'occurrence je pense que il faut il
faut il faut relier cette réforme au
reste des basses besognes d'emmanuel
macron emmanuel macron je le rappelle
après un an de gilet jaune avait dit il
y aura un volet 2 dans mon quinquennat
et ce sera un volet social
écoutez cet été on a eu la 112 la pire
réforme de l'unedic pour stigmatiser les
chômeurs et là maintenant on se coltine
la réforme la plus récente sur les
hollandais se dire tiens ça peuvent plus
faire des émules l'assurance chômage est
passé emmanuel mais je considère et bien
je pense que la conséquence avait très
clair gers et elle est comme le nez au
milieu du visage
emmanuel macron est le laquais le plus
élevé du patronat depuis 1945
à côté de lui même nicolas sarkozy
apparaît pour un amateur donc les quatre
évasion le coc politique pour emmanuel
macron sera terrible mais attention les
mobilisations ne sont pas terminées on
n'en a pas fini avec cette bataille je
peux vous le dire moi qui suis au milieu
de mes camarades je peux vous assurer
qu'on en a pas fini sur cette bataille
là caroline mécary
non mais très clairement on est dans un
projet politique qui est le
démantèlement de l'état social toujours
moins d'état
et c'est dans cette logique là et là où
on atteint si j'allais dire la limite
c'est qu'on est dans le cadre d'une
constitution qui permet un homme avec
son premier ministre de décider pour
l'ensemble des français et donc c'est on
est on est vraiment à l'opposé de ce que
devrait être un débat démocratique et on
vient de voir avec la mise en place du
49 3 comment y compris au sein de
l'assemblée nationale
il est confisqué
est-ce qu'on peut il me comment est ce
qu'un président peut imaginer qu'une
réforme comme celle des retraites qui
remet en cause l'héritage du conseil
national de la résistance qu'elle est
quand même pour objet d'instituer une
solidarité entre les actifs et ceux qui
cessent de travailler puissent être
discuté en l'espace de même pas trois
semaines à l'assemblée nationale il ya
des choix qui sont faits qui sont de
paris mais en force
parce que ces gens là iront aussi
l'opposition la france insoumise et
communistes en déposant un amendement
sur abonnement de 40 noms mais attendez
ça on va voyager virez moi il ya des
gens qui sont fondamentalement contre ce
projet et qui voit la pensée que
l'opposition est peut-être allé trop
loin et a fourni une excuse a fourni une
excuse parfaite au gouvernement reste un
prétexte
très sincèrement c'est un prétexte il
suffisait en réalité oeuvre ils avaient
leurs prénoms mais si le gouvernement
avait été de bonne foi si ce parlement
avait été de bonne foi
d'abord on aurait commencé par
réellement faire de la concertation et
non pas faire semblant
ensuite on aurait tenu compte de l'avis
du conseil d'état qui est quand même un
conseil d'état ce ne sont pas des
affreux gauchiste ce sont des gens qui
ont l'habitude de peser leurs mots et
qui disent très clairement que ce projet
en fait n'est ni fait ni à faire
on n'aurait pas eu une étude d'impact
qui fait mille pas eu mille pages qui
est du d'un manque de rigueur absolue
c'est à dire qu'on aurait eu un
gouvernement qui aurait temporisé qui
aurait écouté qui au lieu de sortir le
49-3 aurait dit bon ok j'entends je
comprends on va remettre ça à plat on
suspend la preuve on suspend la l'art et
la réforme et on voit quels sont les
points d'achoppement
mais comme en réalité le projet
politique ça reste les retraites pas
plus de 14% du pib
et comme on veut pouvoir le faire très
tranquillement on va mettre en place la
retraite à points avec la valeur d'un
point qu'il est même pas indexé sur un
indice qu'on connaît ce qui est quand
même absolument invraisemblable de voilà
on en est là benjamin amaral armées
édouard philippe et sa gamme de rassurer
en disant on a tenu compte des points
oui de l'opposition etc ce qui dit elle
alors débuter alors je vais répondre à
ça que je vais aussi répondre parce que
vous avez pointé que c'est très
important
oui mais alors vous savez chez les
maquereaux nist on est comme chez les
orwelliens c'est à dire que c'est comme
dans 1984 les mots veulent dire l'
inverse de leur sens savez je crois que
c'est monsieur est ce que c'est le
remplit traces en ch'ti qui a dit qu'on
avait un 49,3 de rassemblement voyez
vous on va bientôt inventé les bonbons
dentaire et la crinière des choses alors
écrit c'est très simple par rapport à ce
que vous avez pointé le est-ce qu'on
peut d'abord rappeler quand même c'est
très étonnant
monsieur le maire et monsieur macron
nous disait à l'automne on a énormément
de temps on a beaucoup de temps on
prendra tout le temps là maintenant
c'est la course contre la montre je
rappelle il me semble que c'est marc
fesneau qui a dit si on avait continué à
ce rythme eh bien on aurait mis deux
mois et demi à boucler le débat c'est
trop deux mois et demi pour parler des
retraites
je rappelle juste à titre de mémoire que
au moment où on a parlé de la
privatisation de tf1 on a eu un débat
parlementaire de deux mois je rappelle
que le rythme des amendements lors de la
deuxième semaine était de 90 amendements
par jour ce qui est un très bon rythme
en réalité pendant ce débat on n'a pas
fait que parler des adverbes comme le
dit la macro ni avec ses éléments de
langage on a parlé par exemple de deux
il ya des lièvres qui ont été levés par
exemple sur la question de la valeur du
point
savez là vous prenez censé être mis sur
les salaires et qui maintenant se
rassurent un indice fumeux qu'il reste à
construire
et comme par hasard c'est pas le 49-3 il
tombe pas comme par hasard il arrive
alors que les régimes spéciaux ont été
traités et que la abords des arrivées
des sujets sur lequel la macro ni est en
difficulté sur le financement parce que
j'ai dit il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes
sur le financement est également sur la
valeur du point
c'est une immense manipulation cette
histoire justement la conférence de
financement caroline mécary avant
d'interroger le principal intéressé du
soir la cgt qui a claqué la porte
aujourd'hui après fourrière est ce que
c'est une bonne solution de claquer la
porte est ce parce qu' edouard philippe
a prévenu si on trouve pas d'accord il
va le faire passer son âge pivot donc
est ce que vous le craignez
désormais mais non je crains rien du
tout je pense que les syndicats ont
raison de ne pas vouloir être dans cette
mascarade d'être l'alibi d'un
gouvernement qui de toute façon a déjà
décidé c'est à dire que pourquoi les
syndicats ont claqué la porte
tout simplement parce que pour edouard
philippe il était clair que impossible
de toucher à la question la cotisation
patronale
pourtant l'augmentation de la cotisation
patronale de croiser si je ne me trompe
pas de 0 3% permet de financer
en réalité les retraites de manière
indolore et donc à partir du moment où
on vous dit c'est pas il n'y a pas de
discussion sur cette cotisation
eh bien je pense que les armes ont
raison c'est il ya d'autres manières de
2,2 financés bas jamais à marle le mot
de la fin désolé ça arrive très vite et
c'est très simple et vous n'aviez pas le
choix vous sentir
nous sommes venus d'abord on va couper
court tout de suite à l'idée qu'il ya
convient on fait la politique de la
chaise vide on est venu avec un
économiste spécialiste de la question
michael zemmour on a présenté il a
présenté toutes les propositions de
financement alternative et solidaire que
nous avons sauf que c'est clairement
vous savez c'est comme dans le film de
de jacques tati il ya des roues il ya
des sens interdits partout et on nous
dit voilà bien bienvenue dans la
discussion mais c'est une plaisanterie
on a donc écrit un mais à un courrier à
edouard philippe
pour le dire répondez à nos propositions
autrement ça sert à rien il ne nous
répond pas il est hors de question pour
eux effectivement d'accepter autre chose
que de la sueur du sang des larmes et
des sacrifices pour les travailleurs et
ben claque la porte ça fait deux ans et
demi que mes camarades de la cgt se
coltine ce simulacre de négociation et
cib et n'diaye il ya encore quelques
semaines
oser dire que la cgt faisait la
politique de la chaise vide alors ça
fait deux ans et demi qu'on se coltine
ce calvaire
donc maintenant la mascarade ça suffit
on claque la porte et il était bien
temps merci en tout cas oui désolé on
arrive à la 70 milles avocats qui sont
en grève
ce ne sont pas des idiots c'est bien
parce qu'il n'y a absolument aucune
avancée ni pour eux ni pour lise on les
a reçus régulièrement expliqué je le
sais bien mais dont mais c'est vous
c'est vous dire que les gens ne font pas
grève pour le plaisir
c'est qu'il ya de vraies raisons c'est
bien parce qu'il n'y a personne d'adessa
ici je me permets de ces deux je pense
que c'est vraiment important
merci en tout cas caroline mécary
benjamin a marre d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france 212,4
coronavirus confirmés en france ce soir
c'est 21 de plus que lundi un quatrième
décès étaient enregistrés emmanuel
macron était en visite ce soir au centre
de crise du ministère de la santé qui a
déclaré ce matin les blocs et 260
millions d'euros d' aide pour les
hôpitaux écouter dans cette période que
nous vivons et que nous allons vivre
parce que nous sommes entrés dans une
phase qui va durer des semaines et même
sans doute des mois il est indispensable
d'avoir la clarté la résilience le
sang-froid et la détermination pour
freiner d'abord l'épidémie ce que nous
sommes en train de faire puis lutter
contre celle-ci nous devons tous avoir
conscience que nous sommes et serons
mobilisés dans la durée mais nous sommes
prêts je sais que nous aurons cette
force de relever ce défi et parmi les
régions les plus touchées en france à
l'oise la haute savoie ou encore le
morbihan le ministre de l'économie bruno
le maire assure qu'il n'ya pas de risque
de pénurie et met en garde contre la
spéculation sur les gels
hydroalcooliques françois teschitsch
dépistage matinale pour des élèves du
collège jean de la fontaine de crépy en
valois
c'est dans cet établissement scolaire
que l'enseignant de 60 ans décédé du
coronavirus dans la nuit du 25 au 26
février
travailler là on va faire le dépistage
pour les filles ce que dit qu'elle était
dans la même classe que le professeur
donc on va voir si il ya quelque chose
mais jusque-là bons mâles a pas eu de
fièvre a là rien eu
donc on verra bien je pense pas que l ai
attrapé
on nous a convoqués hier j'étais au
travail gérer ses messages comme quoi il
fallait que je ramène à mon fils pour
l'été c'est médical parce que le procès
qui les cds c'était son pouce et des
technologies
dans les magasins de nombreux rayons de
première nécessité ont été pris d'assaut
mais le ministre de l'économie se veut
rassurant il n'y a pas de problème
d'approvisionnement
ni de risque de pénurie il n'y a pas de
pénurie chaud si tout le monde se rue
sur les produits dans les grands
magasins et dans les grandes surfaces
aussi chacun se met à faire des stocks
de riz de pâtes dominé râle de fruits de
légumes ou de viande bien entendu qu'il
pourra y avoir de la pénurie
mais si chacun adopte un comportement
responsable et un comportement de
consommation normale et classique que
vous achetez ce dont j'ai besoin pour
vous même et pour votre famille soit au
jour le jour ce soit de manière
hebdomadaire
y a pas de risque de pénurie pas de
pénurie non plus des gels hydro
alcooliques mais bruno le maire met en
garde contre d'éventuelles spéculations
un décret pourrait même en fixer le prix
si une augmentation significative et
constater si nous nous apercevons que
par rapport aux prix des gels
hydroalcooliques en petites quantités en
grande quantité qu'ils étaient pratiqués
avant la crise les prix ont doublé
triplé ou quadruplé
elle nous prendrons les mesures
nécessaires mais nécessaire c'est très
simple c'est un décret qui fixera les
prix et qui interdira toute spéculation
sur les prix des gels hydro-alcooliques
personne ne peut accepter qu'il y ait la
moindre spéculation sur la crise du
corps d'un virus concernant les matches
de football et de rugby prévue ce week
end ils ne sont pour l'instant soumis à
aucune restriction particulière annoncé
la ministre des sports la situation
reste évolue-t-il précise roxana
maracineanu et chaque manifestation sera
étudiée au cas par cas est la france est
devenue l'un des principaux foyers du
virus en europe avec l'allemagne et
l'italie l'italie qui agissent dans sept
nouveaux morts depuis hier soir au total
de 79 décès ailleurs dans le monde la
corée du sud deuxième pays le plus
touché après la chine recense près de
5000 caille 28 morts iron annoncent
elles
onze nouveaux décès bilan total 77 morts
si l'essai aux etats-unis où le
président mike pence à nantes qu'un
traitement contre le virus pourraient
être disponibles d'ici à l'été et pour
en parler nous sommes avec vincent
maréchal spécialiste en virologie
bonsoir vincent marissal merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous tout d'abord je voulais
m'arrêter quelques secondes un
traitement disponible avant l'été nous
dit mike pence
vous y croyez alors on a il faut quand
même savoir qu'on a aujourd'hui toute
une liste de molécules qui existe dans
les pharmacies pour d'autres
applications et qu' il ya un certain
nombre d'essais cliniques sont lancés un
peu partout dans le monde pour tester
ces molécules et peut-être qu'avec un
peu de chance dans le lot on trouvera
une molécule qui sera utilisable au
rejet pas de détails sur l'annoncé
américaine
mais il ya des essais très actif pour
essayer tester des molécules oui alors
212 cas en france quatre décès emmanuel
macron qui nous dit que ça peut durer
cette phase en tout cas des semaines
voire des mois quelle est votre réaction
de professeurs de médecine alors pas de
médecine de virologie mais voilà alors
bas ce qu'on essaye de faire aujourd'hui
c'est de regarder ce qui se passe
ailleurs
alors les informations de chine montrent
qu'à une réduction du nombre de cas
déclarés chaque jour alors est ce que ça
tient aux mesures qui ont été prises par
la chine est ce que ça tient compte de
deux modifications de comportement etc
le saura bientôt c'est une épidémie qui
aurait enfin ça c'est sûr alors savoir
quand ça c'est une question pour
laquelle on peut pas répondre
aujourd'hui on est aujourd'hui dans une
phase où le virus circule sur le
territoire par groupe et on sent que les
groupes sont de plus en plus diffus donc
le virus va circuler assez librement ce
qui veut dire qu'on prend des mesures
heure par heure qui évoluent en fonction
de la situation alors quelle est la
conduite à tenir parce qu on en est
resté aux voilà à l'invitation à rester
à la maison quand on revient de zones à
risques un voile à singapour la chine
l'italie
mais alors quid des régions de l'oise du
morbihan ça veut dire que devrait pas
totalement la question comme ça ce qui
est important que les gens comprennent
c'est qu'il ya une gradation dans la
réponse à une gradation dans la
situation quand on a dit aux gens qui
venaient de zones à risque de rester à
la maison c'était parce qu'on voulait au
maximum dans la première phase dans le
stade un c'est de limiter l'arrivée du
virus sur le territoire
la phase 2 qui visait à laisser les gens
à la maison c'était pour éviter de
laisser le virus circule et on voit que
virus circule donc la phase 1 s'est
terminé la phase 2 on allait bien
engagée et on commence à réfléchir à la
phase iii au stade 3 du plan alors le
stade iii est un stade qui est plus
complexe dans les mesures qui seront
prises au cas des mesures qui sont
d'abord des mesures de sanitaires très
importante donc l'idée c'est que dans
les hôpitaux on concentre les cas les
plus graves ceux qui nécessitent une
prise en charge médicale
on va solliciter probablement mobiliser
l'ensemble des personnels de santé pour
faire en sorte qu'en ville les cas les
moins graves puissent être pris en
charge par les médecins et par les
structures plus des structures plus
légères et puis un troisième point qui
est important c'est de protéger faut pas
l'oublier les gens les plus sensibles un
des points importants c'est que cela le
taux de mortalité est le taux de gravité
augmente avec l'âge donc il va falloir
mettre en place des barrières pour
empêcher notamment les gens dans les
ehpad d'être contaminés donc ça veut
dire aujourd'hui que pour vous les
mesures la dictée par le gouvernement ne
sont plus tellement adapté d'une
certaine façon elle soit un prêt se
dépasser non elles sont pas les gens
réagissent au fur et à mesure de
l'évolution de l'épidémie on peut pas
mettre en place des dispositifs on est
on est partis faut bien comprendre qu'on
est parti de mesures qui étaient des
mesures individuelles et qu'on arrive à
un stade où les mesures redevenir
collective
alors je pense que les mesures qui vont
être données voix de différentes natures
et on va aussi demander aux gens
beaucoup plus de responsabilisation dans
les entreprises dans les structures
identifier les postes ou des postes les
plus à risque les postes qu'on doit
maintenir les activités qu'on doit
maintenir et puis dire aux gens dont
l'activité peut être fait à domicile par
exemple de rester à la maison
ça va s'organiser mais chacun se
responsabilise aussi pour vous il ya une
clairement une surréaction peut-être une
forme de psychose dans le pays alors sur
réaction c'est toujours un terme la
suite à la réaction dans une situation
comme ça c'est normal qu'une réaction ou
sur réaction ça c'est difficile ce
projet alors il ya la surréaction il ya
en termes de mesure où en termes
d'individus s'est pas tout à fait la
même ce que je vois c'est des gens très
angoissée
et finalement quand on discute un peu
avec eux qui se désengage quand on leur
explique par exemple aux parents que les
enfants sont pas les premières cibles et
bien des angoisses un petit peu les
parents quand on explique que les
personnes les plus à l'est plus à risque
sont des gens qui ont plus de 60 70 ans
quand on voit les cas les plus graves
on a tous des peines non mais bien sûr
donc non mais ça permet de concentrer
l'attention sur les gens les plus
sensibles voilà a fortiori s'ils ont des
caractères de 6 à des facteurs de
comorbidité diabète hypertension il faut
faire attention aux gens les plus
fragiles aujourd'hui est donc quelle est
la conduite à tenir pour justement alors
aujourd'hui à vous connais pas forcément
des grands parents à titre individuel
voilà à titre individuel limitée
peut-être les contacts avec les
personnes les plus âgées ou les plus
fragiles donc ces personnes là sont
peut-être des personnes qui doivent
prendre un peu plus de précautions
éviter les contacts sociaux maximum
après je pense qu'il faut aussi être
raisonnable on va pas arrêter de vivre
il faut continuer à trouver un modus
vivendi et rendre compatibles les
activités qu'on doit conduire avoir une
vie sociale avec effectivement un
certain nombre de réserves on prend
l'habitude de ne plus serrer la main de
pas se faire la bise
bon bah voilà en revanche moi je prends
le métro et le rer tous les matins on
voit que la situation n'a pas changé
effectivement les gens donc mon père a
perturbé que ça dans le métro on va voir
quand on rentre dans ce stade trois
justement quelles mesures pourraient
être prises sur les rassemblements la
taille des rassemblements sur la
circulation sur les transports
l'approvisionnement ces questions là
vous êtes reposé et on va vraiment il
répond progressivement vous disiez toute
épidémie a une fin qu'est ce qui selon
vous
pour émettre fin celle ci il ya
plusieurs hypothèses aujourd'hui
on a fait beaucoup de parallèles avec le
virus de la grippe faut savoir qu'à
d'autres coronavirus qui sont beaucoup
plus bénins qui circulent en france
chaque année cela nous préoccupe pas
beaucoup et on sait que ce sont des
virus qui aiment le froid qui aiment
humidité qui sont quittes dont la
transmission est plus facile divers
auxquels première hypothèse qui consiste
à dire et ça on le dit depuis très
longtemps de ce genre la sortie de
l'hiver changement de climat
ça devrait régresser maintenant
comparaison n'est pas raison et le
coronavirus a sa vie propre
donc on va surveiller surtout et vous
reviendrez nous voir on l'espère merci
vincent maréchal professeur en virologie
merci à vous dans quelques instants
rester avec nous on parlera l'union
européenne qui promet toute l'aide
nécessaire à la grèce face à l'afflux de
milliers de migrants via la turquie et
puis nous reviendrons sur le super
tuesday pas moins de quatorze états
américains sont appelés aux urnes
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
on a de plus en plus de personnes qui
sont atteints d'obésité
on a de plus en plus d'enfants qui sont
en baisse de plus en plus tôt l'obésité
génère 18 autres maladies derrière
apnées du sommeil diabète cancer
l'hypertension artérielle infertilité
hommes et femmes
moi ce que je vois c'est ce que ça coûte
aux individus en terme psychologique en
terme médical en termes sociétale en
termes professionnels et ça ça fait des
dégâts considérables
ce qui est fait en france par an chose
pour pas dire rien ça ne se soigne pas à
coup de spots télé ça ne se soigne pas à
coups de livres ça se soigne avec des
véritables médecin tout ce qui peut être
fait c'est pas moi je peux passer ce cap
c'est faux ça commence chez soi tout de
suite maintenant
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de fine
stratégie peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire je suis relax chômeurs et
chaque semaine dans l'échiquier mondial
nous analyserons les coups les plus
complexes du jeu politique
internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france bonsoir
bienvenue sur rt feront si vous nous
rejoignez 20h30 heure française l'union
européenne promet toute l'aide
nécessaire à athènes et dirigeants
européens se sont rendus aujourd'hui
dans la ville frontalière de caste et
nièces en grèce est les pays membres de
l'ue eux ont donné leur accord pour
l'intervention rapide de frontex
l'agencé européenne de contrôle des
frontières il s'agit d'aider la grèce à
faire face à l'afflux de migrants de
milliers de migrants ou via la turquie d
arriver en masse depuis que recep tayyib
erdogan a ouvert sa frontière
voyez le récit de florian lambert
l'union européenne joue la carte de la
solidarité en grèce alors que des
milliers de migrants sont toujours
stoppés à la frontière gréco turque
les dirigeants européens se réunissent
et en urgence aujourd'hui au poste
frontalier de caste à nice la présidente
de l'union européenne
ursula von der leyen a tenu à affirmer
un soutien total de l'europe à la grèce
dépassé par ce conflit humanitaire les
autorités grecques font face à cette
difficile tâche qui consiste à contenir
cette situation je voudrais remercier
les gardes frontière et les gardes côtes
grecs
je voudrais remercier les civils les
agents et agentes de police et je
voudrais remercier frontex pour la
réaction à fatigue amex il est important
pour moi d'être ici avec vous
aujourd'hui et vous dire que
l'appréhension des grecs est aussi la
nôtre
cette frontière n'est pas seulement
grecque mais aussi européenne et à ce
titre je suis ici en tant qu'européenne
un soutien public et matérielles la
présidente de l'union européenne promet
une aide financière de 700 millions
d'euros à athènes afin de répondre aux
enjeux d'une nouvelle vague migratoire à
la demande de la grèce l' agence
européenne de surveillance des
frontières frontex se dit prête à
déployer une force rapide comprenant
notamment un navire de patrouille heures
deux hélicoptères et un avion sans
gardes-frontières européens
supplémentaires seront déployés
s'ajoutant aux 530 déjà présents
concernés par la politique agressive de
recep tayyip erdogan en syrie la russie
souhaite également apporter son aide à
l'europe
nous comprenons pleinement la complexité
du problème des migrants pour l'union
européenne je l' ai déjà dit un dialogue
est en cours entre la fédération de
russie et la diplomatie européenne et
nous allons poursuivre de son côté la
france par le biais du ministre des
affaires étrangères jean yves le drian
condamne fermement le comportement de la
turquie
nous avons demandé le président de la
république au président poutine de faire
cesser cette offensive dite libre d'en
revenir aux cadres de sotchi mais la
solidarité doit aller dans les deux sens
et l' usage par la turquie des migrants
comme moyen de pression et de chantage
sur l'europe est absolument inacceptable
pendant ce temps là des dizaines de
milliers de personnes attendent toujours
de savoir leur prochaine destination
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude bloch maison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous le
président turc erdogan qui continue donc
de mettre la pression sur l'europe en
donnant l'impression que les frontières
sont grandes ouvertes pour obtenir son
soutien en syrie est ce que c'est une
bonne stratégie
d'une certaine manière il a tout à fait
réussie puisque aujourd'hui les
présidents des trois principales
institutions européennes sont sur la
frontière gréco-turque naturellement
côté grec pour manifester la solidarité
européenne avec l'état membre qui est la
grèce qui a une frontière avec la
turquie et qui est directement menacé
par l'afflux de réfugiés venant de
turquie donc ursula von der leyen
a en effet promis des moyens elle a même
annoncé 700 millions d'euros ce qui est
tout à fait considérable ça a été décidé
en très peu de temps
le président du conseil européen est
présent avec elle c'est très rare il se
déplaçant même avec elle ainsi que le
président du parlement européen donc
politiquement la réponse est là l'europe
sera solidaire et je crois que par
ailleurs naturellement les moyens
financiers les moyens techniques seront
mises en oeuvre
puisque l' agence frontex qui a démarré
très péniblement il ya 15 ans dispose
maintenant d'un certain nombre de moyens
de garde frontière et qui seront
disposés et puis en plus évidemment il
est possible que tel ou tel état membre
conclu des accords bilatéraux avec la
grèce pour apporter des moyens
supplémentaires donc la grèce sera
protégé de cet influent de cet afflux
que dont erdogan nous mener c'est
d'abord ils font peut-être aussi
remarquer que l'origine de toute cette
affaire c'est qu'un certain nombre de
gens ne veulent pas vivre en syrie sous
le régime de bachar el assad et qui sont
partis se réfugier ailleurs
en effet 3 3 millions peut-être même 4
millions sont réfugiés en turquie
dans des camps et qu'en réalité ils
n'ont qu'une envie c'est d'en partir
pour se diriger vers vers l'europe parce
que c'est pour eux l'eldorado et que
tous ceux qui sont enfermés en syrie
encore dans la poche d'idlib
il y en a environ 3 millions ne rêve que
de suivre le même chemin via la turquie
pour ensuite aller en europe donc il ya
en effet un problème considérable et je
crois que l'union européenne là dessus a
décidé de le prendre de le prendre à
bras le corps puisque demain les mises
l'intérieur se réunissent une que le 6
vendredi prochain des mises affaires
étrangères se réunissent et que des
décisions seront prises par ces
institutions
monsieur borel qui est le représentant
de la politique étrangère et de sécurité
de l'union européenne lui est
actuellement à ankara avec le
membre de la commission le commissaire
chargée des questions humanitaires pour
avoir des discussions pendant deux jours
avec les autorités turques parce que
bien entendu la turquie est un pays
associé à l'union européenne elle a des
relations particulières avec l'union
européenne et il est tout à fait normal
qu'on en discute alors on en discute et
surtout on a envie de trouver un accord
qu'est-ce que peut et doit négocier
l'europe face à ce chantage migratoire
de la turquie je crois que dans un
premier temps c'est la position qui a
été prise
le refus du chantage migratoires et puis
par ailleurs il faut en effet discuté
éventuellement de solutions concrètes
alors lorsque la première vague
migratoire qui était bien plus
importante que l'actuel en 2015 a
commencé la chancelière merkel avait
pris l'initiative de discuter avec
monsieur erdogan et puis finalement
l'union européenne a conclu un accord en
au terme duquel l'union européenne a
promis un peu plus de 6 milliards
d'euros pour aider non pas le
gouvernement turc
mais les associations qui s'occupent des
réfugiés en turquie là dessus plus de
quatre milliards et demi ont déjà été
engagées trois milliards et demi ont été
déboursés par conséquence un système qui
fonctionne est en effet sous cette sous
le régime de cet accord le nombre de
réfugiés turc qui prenait le chemin de
l'union européenne a drastiquement
diminué alors dans le même temps et
aussi l'europe qui promet toute l'aide
nécessaire aux côtés de la grèce mais
quelle aide peut-être promettre quel
montant mais aussi concrètement qu'est
ce que ça peut donner sur le terrain
je crois qu'il ya d'abord
en effet la fermeture de la frontière
l'armée grecque la police grecque sont
bien équipés les dépenses grec pour la
défense du pays s'en sont importantes
elle a l'habitude d'avoir des relations
compliquées avec la turquie
par conséquent cette frontière est
verrouillé alors ce que ce que va
apporter l'union européenne c'est
d'abord 1500 personnes de frontex plus
un certain nombre de navires un certain
nombre d'équipements de façon à aider à
la surveillance de cette frontière et
par conséquent la verrouiller plus en
plus
en effet certains états membres vont
apporter une aide complémentaire
et puis lé fameux 700 millions d'euros
qui permettront d'aider la grèce est
d'aider la grèce pour les réfugiés qui
sont déjà parce que dans les villes de
lesbos de samos il y a en effet quantité
de réfugiés avec des problèmes
considérables que ça peut poser pour la
population locale alors une rencontre
est prévue en ce jeudi à mons contre
vladimir poutine et recep tayyip erdogan
qu'est ce qu'on peut en attendre les
rapports entre vladimir poutine et recep
erdogan son saut sont complexes sont
intéressants parce que complexe
effectivement d'abord ils soutiennent
pas le même côté puisque la délire
poutine soutient depuis le début bachar
el-assad et que recep erdogan au
contraire étaient hostiles au maintien
de bachar el-assad et soutenait les
rebelles qui luttait contre lui mais il
n'empêche que poutine et recep erdogan
se respecte et ont réussi à conclure un
certain nombre d'accords pour ménager
leur intérêt réciproque
ça a été le cas en 2018 pour assurer une
sorte de neutralisation de la zone 10 de
lives avec le fait que la russie a
accepté que la turquie et 18 postes
militaires de contrôle dans cette zone
dv d'idlib pour pour surveiller
l'ensemble de la zone
quitte à ce qu'elle neutralise
les combattants ce qu'elle n'a pas
véritablement réalisé en 2019
il ya eu également un deuxième accord de
sotchi entre erdogan et poutine
et là aussi il s'agissait de décider de
ce qui serait fait après le retrait
américain dans la zone que les kurdes
c'était obligé de quitter puisqu'il
n'avait plus le soutien américain avec
lesquels il
il combattait et l'armée turque a envahi
cette zone puisque elle ne voulait pas
en effet que les kurdes prennent trop
d'importance
y compris en syrie au nord de la syrie
donc à toute cette zone qui est occupé
par l'armée turque
les rues sont limitées cette zone d'une
zone tampon avec des patrouilles mixtes
russe et turc et ça a fait l'objet d'un
accord et il y a un an
on peut penser que ce qui va se passer
lors de la prochaine rencontre le 5 ce
sera une sorte de nouvel accord mais ne
sera pas l'accord de sotchi ce sera la
corde moscou 7 fois et il est probable
que ceci aboutira à retarder la chute
d'idlib
ceci à vous dira peut-être à diminuer le
nombre de postes militaires de contrôle
turc est évidemment erdogan cherchera à
obtenir de poutine des garanties pour la
zone nord tampon qu'il voudrait
contrôler et ils veulent à contrôler au
sud de la frontière entre la syrie et la
turquie
en réalité pour y installer des réfugiés
et ceci est assez dangereux car je ne
suis pas sûr que l'union européenne
puisse accepter un système pérenne
d'installation de réfugiés anti bachar
par conséquent dans le nord de la syrie
sous surveillance ou sous garantie russo
turque
merci beaucoup aux claude blanchou
maison pour votre analyse mercier
aux etats unis ouverture des primaires
démocrates 14 états vote lors de ce
super tuesday étape déterminante pour
départager les favoris bernie sanders et
joe biden elle l'ancien vice-président
le vent en poupe après avoir assemblé le
camp modéré dans la course à la maison
blanche
derrière la lutte est intense pour
passer les 15% et obtenir des supers
d'habitation peut tous nous entrons dans
le super tuesday en virginie et je crois
très fermement que les gens de ce pays
pour le super tuesday et après vont
soutenir notre campagne parce que nous
sommes plus qu'une campagne
nous sommes un mouvement pitbull hadjadj
est out
tous ces votes pour le super tuesday
iront à joe biden l'endormi excellent
timing c'est le vrai début de
l'élimination de bernis par les
démocrates
encore une fois pas de nomination si on
perd le texas nous n'aurons plus jamais
de président républicain de notre vivant
si le tarn county tombe le texas tombe
et si le texas tombe adieu donald trump
à paris également en votes lors de ce
super tuesday des précisions de notre
reporter katia technique dans le 7e
arrondissement de la capitale
c'est le super tuesday étape cruciale
pour les primaires démocrates américaine
14 étapes ont voté comme le colorado le
texas ou encore la californie ainsi que
les îles samoa et puis un seizième
scrutin les américains de l'étranger ici
à paris à l'église américaine ce sont
les américains de france qui vont voter
pour le premier jour ils ont jusqu'au 10
mars
ils se sont pressés aujourd'hui dans ce
bâtiment pour désigner un candidat
démocrate
il y a encore cinq candidats en lice
deux font la course en tête tout d'abord
bernie sanders le favori des sondages le
très social qui se bat pour la sécurité
sociale il est crédité de 29%
d'intentions de vote derrière lui joe
biden l'ancien vice-président de barack
obama
c'est lui le favori du parti mais il
n'est crédité que de 17% d'intentions de
vote est encore derrière michael
bloomberg avec 15% malgré des frais de
campagne exorbitants 400 millions juste
en frais de campagne
ici donc je vous disais les électeurs
américains sont nombreux et ils veulent
absolument que berck donald trump perdre
les prochaines élections je vous propose
de les écouter
oui pour moi c'est très important de
voter pour vous êtes très important de
voter tout court mais surtout pour les
eyzies dès qu'on a déjà en france on a
déjà les choses comme la sécurité
sociale on a déjà une université qui
coûte pas très cher donc pour moi c'est
très important même si on habite à
l'étranger de l'étrangère de voter pour
pour améliorer le pays même si on n'y
habitent pas on paie toujours les impôts
en tant qu'américain donc c'est toujours
très important de faire partie de 2,2
tout ça et de voter quand on peut cette
élection est tellement importante c'est
les enjeux énormes
d'habitude je vote toujours mais je suis
moins engagés et là je veux vraiment
participer je veux vraiment sentir les
autres je veux j'ai la foi a je pense
que c'est 70% des américains sans pour
la sécurité sociale
mais on a peur de ce mot socialiste
communiste et mais c'est vraiment pas le
cas il ya beaucoup d'américains surtout
les jeunes qui savent que en fait c'est
pas très différent ce qu'on l'a en
europe et pour eux et pour nous c'est
très important de deux de voter pour
pouvoir dire que c'est notre pays et
qu'on vous ça et on veut pas mourir
parce qu'on est pauvre on on veut avoir
des aides sociales
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis washington avec robert pattison
ratej démocrate c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir robert pétillot merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
imagine que vous attendez cette soirée
avec beaucoup d'impatience
il ya beaucoup d'enjeu pour vous ce soir
d'enjeu il détaille ce soir il ya encore
beaucoup de délégués à la californie à
500 délégués des états comme la chine
qui s'est tu as déjà à presque 100
délégués donc nous pourrions voir un
gagnant des primaires en fonction de ce
qui se produit ce soir vous ce soir une
certaine manière on va clairement
connaître celui qui affrontera donald
trump heures novembre prochain on peut
dire ça ou c'est un petit peu quand même
précipité comme une conclusion ça leur
est trop tôt pour en tirer des
conclusions
surtout parce que nous avons encore du
hope hayden qui est qui participent à la
course et qui va avoir de bons résultats
aussi des états unis il y a encore de
l'essence qui va être populaire en
qualifs californie ou dans au nord-est
et on entendra aussi maire de new york
michael qui est milliardaire qui a
défense énormément d'argent dans cette
campagne
donc nous ne savons pas quels effets
vont avoir les millions de dollars qu'il
a dépensés pour ça commence sa compagne
alors on le sait en tout cas que bernie
sanders pour le moment et est très
favoris je crois qu'il est dix points
d'avancé par rapport au deuxième et
effectivement joe biden qui après sa
victoire en caroline du sud a été
revigorée pour vous il y aura
non désormais quand même un suspense les
dés ne sont pas jetés justement en
faveur de bernie sanders
pas du tout je pense qu est à nice 1 2
s'en sort très bien avec une minorité d
électeurs américains
mais il faut comprendre qu'il a gagné
25% de la vôtre a highway est un objet
aussi un faible pourcentage de la
majorité du parti ne soutient pas sans
doute donc dans la course entre beijing
et sanders
cela va être difficile pour en d3 de se
démarquer et d'avoir le nombre de
délégués dont ils ont besoin pour avoir
l'investiture tout de suite
michael bloomberg beaucoup l'avaient
donné perdant lors de son entrée on
débat il y a dix jours environ vous vous
pensez qu'il a encore des chances parler
de ses dollars qu'il investit on sait
combien c'est très important lors d'une
campagne aux états unis n'a pas de
chance de gagner mais il a une
opportunité des brenets de la course
comme paris mal à récolter des fonds et
donc avec ne dépenser que 4000 dollars
en californie par exemple michael
vineberg pourtant a dépensé plus de 10
millions à 10 millions de dollars
vous risquez aucun autre candidat alors
le rock voudrait que peut jouer dans la
course et de dons faits par nissan est
d'avoir une victoire absolue
les votes sont destinés en fonction du
pourcentage de la vue que l'individu aux
tiens donc
bonbek var est sorti en deuxième place
tant qu'ils avaient fait état dans une
défense beaucoup d'agents de kiel il va
diviser la vôtre ce qui va aider bien
pardonne donc bloomberg en forme de
d'arbitré il ya aussi
d'autres protagonistes qui ont joué un
rôle un pitbull dj jeremy que le bouchât
qui ont tous de jeter l'épongé plutôt en
faveur pour le coup de joe biden tout ça
tout à fait actuellement un mini
sauteurs qui est l'état d' aimer kruger
il est à des publicités de rogers
columbia qui pour soutenir
pas étonnant j'ai passé nous voyons
colonel modérés du parti uni derrière un
candidat qui parle d'une île sera va
l'aider à prendre le dessus sur 100 m
et cela représente entre environ 35% de
de tout tout et voit alors ya un silence
qui se fait remarquer si j'ose dire
c'est celui de barack obama
pourquoi ne s'exprime t-il pas sur ces
primaires barack obama selon vous nous
avons vu par le coupable est aussi il
récolte qui sont restés silencieux quant
à cette course et je pense que c'est
surtout parce qu'il veut être en
position pour prêter des soutiens à
celui qui ressort en premier
elle ne tenait pas faire des choix à ce
stade de la course les deux anciens
présidents en plus coûteuses influence
sur la partie et ils ne veulent pas être
vus en tant que les personnes qui vont
avoir une influence en faveur de
certains candidats ils veulent unir le
parti et je pense que ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas c'est assez souvent que les
anciens présidents agi de cette façon
nous avons vu par le passé que des
choses par exemple il y avait des
anciens présidents qui ne sont pas
exprimés mais les anciens président
essaye de rester à l'écart et de ne pas
exprimer le soutien en faveur d'un
quatre candidats ou un autre revers
pâtir vous vous êtes stratège démocrate
qu'elles sont c'est ma dernière question
vos attentes
ce soir mes attentes
c'est que nous avons aura une vue
partagée par les varois de bons
résultats dans le sud où il ya des
populations minoritaires à l'afro
américaine corning virginie oklahoma et
s'être je pense que il y a beaucoup de
chance que c est à voter pour des
parisiens sands pas avoir de bons
résultats au nord marcel schiess est
vraiment cette menace au tas il va bien
s'en sortir danser et à l'a1 est
important va être le texte sanders a
beaucoup de soutien entre parmi les
communautés hispano latine ici ils
arrivent à avoir beaucoup de crack et
beaucoup de voix au texas et cela va
beaucoup l'aider alors je pense que
l'état c'est l'attaqué qu'il faut
regarder ce soir ses textes pour
déterminer qui va avoir ses chances de
gagner
si paris remporte un texte alors nous
avons demain matin nous allons nous
allons voir nous allons voir que cela va
être difficile
merci beaucoup robert a pâti d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france pour
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur merci à
vous
en afghanistan le porte parole des
taliban et donald trump ont échangé au
téléphone ce soir le président américain
même évoqué une très bonne conversation
avec le chef politique des talibans une
discussion qui fait suite aux nombreuses
attaques menées hier contre des bases
militaires deux jours après la signature
d'un accord historique avec washington
le récit signé rania berrada la trêve
aura été de courte durée
instaurer le 22 février elle n'aura été
respectée que neuf jours par les taliban
qui ont annoncé lundi reprendre leur
offensive contre les forces de sécurité
afghanes
nos moudjahidine n'attaqueront pas les
forces étrangères mais nos opérations
continueront contre les forces du
gouvernement de kaboul
une annonce qui intervient deux jours
seulement après la signature d'un accord
historique entre les taliban et
washington cet accord doit permettre
d'amorcer un retrait des forces
américaines
un texte qui n'est pas synonyme d'un
arrêt total et immédiat des violences
alerte le pentagone ce lundi j'invite
tout le monde à intégrer le fait qu'il
ne va pas y avoir une cessation absolu
de la violence en afghanistan
cela ne va probablement pas arrivé on ne
va pas aboutir à un niveau zéro de la
violence cet accord est un pas en avant
important qui va conduire à un dialogue
inter afghan et au bout du compte un
accord de paix mais penser qu'il va
immédiatement mettre fin à la violence
cela n'arrivera pas pourtant le
président afghan ashraf ghani avait
annoncé dimanche la prolongation de la
trêve partiel elle devait durer au moins
jusqu'au début des discussions en terre
afghane qui doivent débuter le 10 mars
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
à nous reviendrons sur la réforme des
retraites et de recours aux 49 3
nouvelles la manifestation aujourd'hui
en france et deux motions de censure
déposées à l'assemblée des pâtes eu ce
soir puis nous parlerons de la
propagation du coronavirus dans le monde
suscitant l'inquiétude des marchés
pétroliers notamment
[Musique]
comment expliquer que tant de jeunes
s'intéressent aux mma elle peut
permettre c'est important à ces jeunes
qui ont cette énergie dans un espace
réglementés de pouvoir s'épanouir et de
pouvoir
je dirais lâcher cette agressivité cette
haine qu'ils peuvent avoir selon lui il
est violent parce que l'essence même de
la violence
ça commence à partir du moment une
opposition physique quel que soit le
sport le judo la boxe au karaté je pense
que ça serait utopique d'imaginer que
les mavs arrivée des problèmes enjeu de
santé publique mais même à légaliser
fernand lopez sur le groupe ce serait
irresponsable messi
un peu plus de 58 français pratiquer un
sport de manière sauvage la priorité
l'obsession c'est la santé des
pratiquants c'est donc d'encadrer il
leur permet de pouvoir s'épanouir dans
toutes les situations dans tous les
clubs avec le maximum de sécurité comme
la boxe l'est
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a fini maman on a fini mais
mon nom je suis sûr qu'on doit mettre un
terme à cette croissance
et je n'ai jamais vraiment été séduit
par l'idée de mettre des enfants au
monde parce que je sentais que le monde
n'allait pas bien et que la vie serait
synonyme pour eux de souffrance cela
nous ramène à cette idée qu'il n'y a
aucune raison de mettre plus d'enfants
au monde
vous prenez des êtres qui ont besoin
d'amour et voulait leur donner cet amour
personne ne veut en parler car tout le
monde a peur mais la survie de notre
espèce dépend vraiment de notre capacité
à résoudre ce problème s'il ne pouvons
même pas en parler on va avoir de gros
problèmes
[Musique]
au printemps il verra t-on équipements
et le cas sera en morceaux et hausse et
il prendra ton âme qui et puis le fait
qu'il a dit
[Musique]
hmmmm avant il y avait trois chaman
maintenant ils sont beaucoup les
pèlerins ceux qui sont venus pour un
service de prières par là
oh
[Musique]
et agnel parfois on n'a que des
éléphanteaux victimes de braconnage
particulièrement brutale car
malheureusement les bébés sont souvent
témoin non seulement du meurtre de leur
mère mais aussi la voix se faire
massacrer et découper une brochette radu
je crois que les éléphants sourient
c'est ce que je vois chez les petits et
leurs expressions faciales change
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mardi le gouvernement face aux deux
motions censure de la gauche et de la
droite elles sont débattues à
l'assemblée nationale ce soir alors que
les opposants à la réforme était dans la
rue aujourd'hui
ils étaient vingt mille à paris selon
les syndicats la crise du coronavirus
quatrième morts recensés en france sur
deux sont tous cas confirmés dans
l'hexagone
emmanuel macron participera mercredi
matin un conseil de défense spéciale
dédiée aux coronavirus l'inquiétude
gagne aussi et les marchés le pétrole
est une des matières et plus touchée
avec des cours très bas
une réunion de l'opep se tiendra jeudi
et vendredi à vienne afin d'essayer de
trouver un accord sur une réduction de
l'offre mondiale
aux etats unis c'est le super tuesday ce
soir une date cruciale pour les
candidats aux primaires démocrates 14
états vont voter en même temps un moment
clé dans le calendrier électoral pour
désigner celui ou celle qui devra
affronter donald trump dans la course à
la maison blanche
le super mardi quelles sont les gens ces
enjeux le favori bernie sanders peut-il
creusé son avance sur les autres
candidats et sur joe biden et quel
bobard peut-il créer la surprise ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face à 21h30
[Musique]
le recours par le gouvernement aux 49 3
ravive la protestation en france
l'assemblée nationale se penche ce soir
sur les deux motions de censure déposée
par l'opposition de droite et de gauche
notre reporter ses biscuits les débats
on le retrouve tout de suite en direct
de l'assemblée nationale bonsoir baptême
est quoi faut-il s'attendre dans
l'hémicycle ce soir
dapd et stéphanie il faut s'attendre à
beaucoup de discussions beaucoup de
débats autour de ces deux motions de
censure proposé par l'adulte par par les
républicains notre part par la gauche et
la france insoumise ainsi que les
communistes parti socialiste ont signé
cette motion de censure marine le pen
aurait également signé la motion de
censure proposé par la gauche des débats
qui ont commencé très tôt à partir de
15h et qui continueront tout au long de
la soirée on vient d'assister à une ou
un arrêt a fait des discussions une
reprise qui est prévu pour 22h15
l'opposition et bien déterminés à se
faire entendre par le biais de ces deux
motions de censure
il accuse le gouvernement d'avoir eu
recours aux 49 3 dans le cadre de la
réforme des retraites pour faire passer
en force cette réforme ils sont bien
décidés à aller jusqu'au bout de leur
combat certains chefs de file sont
montés à la tribune c'était le cas de
damien abad le chef de file des
républicains qui a parlé d'un
gouvernement qui empêcherait le débat et
l'appareil de l'amateurisme de la
majorité ainsi que ainsi que de se
servir du coronavirus pardon pour
pouvoir passer en force
cette loi il a dit que c'était un
gouvernement qui privilégiait ses
intérêts au détriment des intérêts de la
france les réactions étaient nombreuses
à l'entrée des quatre colonnes avant
cette séance vous proposons d'écouter
quelques unes comme le premier ministre
et le gouvernement ne peuvent pas
répondre aux questions des
parlementaires
eh bien ils passent en force il veut
raccourcir le débat mais je crois que
les français ne seront pas dupes et en
tout cas ce sera donc l'enjeu des
futures élections notamment la
présidentielle pense que tous les
français qui ont compris le cynisme du
gouvernement et surtout la manière dont
il a fait le samedi après avoir fait une
conférence de presse sur le court aux
navires russes enfin tout ça est très
mesquin très petit et vraiment pas à la
hauteur de l'enjeu
dois je voterai des deux motions de
censure l'une de droite ni de gauche
parce que je crois qu'il faut
symboliquement qu'est le maximum de voix
mais je pense que l'enjeu mois je
souhaiterais qu'on est plutôt une motion
référendaire
c'est à dire que si la droite et la
gauche s'entendait
pour demander un référendum d'initiative
populaire qui d'initiative partagée le
terme technique de la constitution nous
pourrions demander aux français ensuite
de signer d'avoir les 4 millions de
signatures nécessaires à l'obligation
pour le gouvernement de tenir un
référendum je vois que ça comme solution
parce que tout le monde sait que les
motions de censure ne seront pas valable
puisque nous n'avons pas la majorité des
discussions très animées comme je lui ai
dit au sein de l'hémicycle le chef du
gouvernement mais monsieur edouard
philippe a été beaucoup critiqué avant
de prendre à son tour la parole depuis
le pupitre il est revenu pour défendre
cette réforme des retraites et surtout
défendre le recours aux 49 3 il a
précisé que ce n'était pas la première
fois dans la vème république ce recours
avait lieu 88 x utilisés par ses
prédécesseurs voilà ce qu'il a annoncé à
l'hémicycle face aux députés qui leur
reprochaient ce passage en force de
cette réforme des retraites il a parlé
d'un outil qui faisait partie de la vie
parlementaire il a dit qu'on devait
avancer sur ce débat il parlait ainsi
que d'une minorité qui bloquerait toute
discussion et qu'ils bloqueraient
l'avancée de cette proposition que le
système de santé français devaient
avancer et s'améliorer voilà pourquoi la
réforme des retraites devrait être
adoptée le gouvernement est bien décidé
à faire passer cette réforme les deux
motions sont sûres comme je l'expliqué
en très peu de chances d'aboutir
ce projet de loi devrait être votée mais
simplement en première lecture ici à
l'assemblée nationale il soit renvoyé à
bien sûr auprès du sénat pour une
nouvelle lecture de nouvelles
discussions à partir de fin avril
prochain en attendant les discussions
continuent ici à l'assemblée nationale
prochaine séance à 22h30 merci bassem
chez vie depuis l'assemblée nationale on
suivra évidemment ça avec vous et pour
protester contre le 49-3 à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale plusieurs
manifestations avaient lieu également en
france dans la rue plus de 20000
personnes mobilisées à paris selon les
syndicats les rassemblements également à
toulouse marseille ou encore lille le
récit de cette journée avec régnard a
berrada
le rendez vous était donné à 13h30 place
de la république le cortège parisien est
finalement parti vers 14h15 dans les
rangs des manifestants des enseignants
des cheminots mais aussi des avocats
toujours fortement mobilisé contre la
réforme des retraites
le prochain
sexuelle sera saisie il déclarera
inconstestablement un certain nombre de
dispositions de ce texte contraire à la
constitution donc il faut rester
mobilisé de ce gouvernement un problème
de dialogue
en réalité il a des lubies il porte une
réforme dogmatique il n'a pas de
réponses aux questions qu'on lui pose
notamment sur la valeur du point et donc
ils préfèrent se servir de cette
épidémie pour faire diversion et pas
répondre aux questions fondamentales qui
se posent dans ce projet de loi au
centre des préoccupations des
manifestants le recours aux 49 3 en
pleine épidémie de coronavirus une façon
pour le gouvernement de passer en force
et de faire fi de leurs revendications
regrette les syndicalistes effet un
conseil des ministres pour parler du
coroner et puis finalement bas il nous
rajoute de la pression sociale quand ils
nous rajoute une petite pièce social
l'après midi avec les 49 3 donc c'est
pas surprenant en même temps bas de
toute façon en 49 3 ou pas c'est le
passage en force quoi qu'il se passe de
7,2 cette réforme donc ça change pas le
fait que de toute façon il faut se
mobiliser le plus largement possible
et évidemment il s'agit pas que de la
réforme des retraites il s'agit de
mettre en échec toute 1 cette politique
libérale qui a montre bien son vrai
visage aujourd'hui parmi les
protestataires figuraient également des
élus mobilisés contre le texte
pour la sénatrice esther benbassa la
décision du gouvernement met en péril la
démocratie il ya eu quand même
enfin un glissement vers une démocratie
autoritaire d'un côté là
la violence des interventions policières
le nombre de blessés le la façon d'agir
à l'endroit des gilets jaunes et de
l'autre côté maintenant on se retrouve
avec un texte qui a été quand même dix
ont bâillonnés avec le 49-3 le cortège
parisien s'est dispersée vers 17 heures
place de la madeleine où l'attendaient
en important dispositif de sécurité
les protestataires n'ont pas pu accéder
aux abords de l'assemblée nationale
comme prive la réforme des retraites
hockey
des milliers de manifestants se sont
rassemblés à marseille à toulouse à
lille ou encore à bordeaux
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
ludovic de la rg expert en communication
également auteur d'un documentaire sur
la réforme des retraites c'est
d'ailleurs son nom bonsoir ludovic et de
l'air
merci d'être avec nous vous avez suivi
évidemment de très près toutes ces
avancées sur cette réforme
quelle est votre réaction avec cet
aboutissement
si on peut parler d'aboutissement le 49
3 et la mobilisation qui continue on
remballe tout ça en fait assez cohérent
finalement ça qu'on a aujourd'hui un
mode de gouvernement qui est la violence
donc là c'est une forme de 7,1 élevé des
parlementaires qui étaient envoyés c'est
un honte hier sur les députés grain car
9,3 pour clore le débat
et puis pour faire passer un texte sans
sembler tous deux interventions du
parlement tout en disant inverse
parce que leurs philippe l'a présenté
comme et d'ailleurs c'est bête ndiaye
également y laisser la pratique du
mensonge du gouvernement c'est que il a
présenté comme une manière de rétablir
le parlement dans sa première fonction
qui est de voter la loi ce qui est bien
entendu complètement inverse est
complètement faux et les discours
aujourd'hui sur les motions de censure à
l'assemblée était assez éclairant et on
a eu quelques belles envolées
et puis en face par contre une attitude
qui est vraiment une attitude de
violence c'est que vraiment c'est 49 3 c
c'est un coup de lb des parlementaires
alors vous avez quoi comme réaction ce
samedi soir on s'attendait pas
nécessairement as 49,3 en catimini en
plein milieu d'un week-end en pleine
crise du coronavirus vous pensez que ça
a été pesé par le gouvernement peut
peser en tout cas on imagine mais enfin
c'est ya une part d'improvisation et
quelles sont les raisons profondes qui
ont conduit le gouvernement devrait en
fait on a la même méthode depuis le
départ ça qu'on a un texte qui est à qui
comporte 28 blanc il est fait par
ordonnance
on a un débat qui réduit à un mois alors
que tous les parlementaires tous
demandaient un mois supplémentaire pour
pouvoir en discuter
donc du coup le nombre d'amendements et
qualifié d' obstruction parce qu'il ya
un mois pour discuter c'est trop court
on parlait d'un projet qui va régir les
50 prochaines années
c'est un projet extrêmement important
lourd ben c'est pas une loi
tout à fait anodine donc c'est c'est
important d'avoir le temps d'en discuter
et puis là bon ben on a annoncé comment
en catimini effectivement parce que
techniquement ça oblige l'opposition à
s'organiser pour voir faire une motion
de censure en 24 heures mais 24 heures
du samedi après midi au dimanche soir
je t'ai fait que tous les parlementaires
ont quasiment passé la nuit à
l'assemblée le temps de recueillir
toutes les signatures
donc c'est assez important dans ce
timing et puis surtout vous avez enfin
vous c'est important les institutions
quand même enfin et moi je suis amoureux
des institutions et du parlement mais le
premier ministre est invité au parlement
il ne peut pas y aller il était invité
par les parlementaires le le seuil de 2
le foyer de la légitimité c'est au
parlement sur les parlementaires qui
sont les élus du peuple et il est venu
parler à l'assemblée invité par son
groupe les autres groupes n'ont pas été
prévenus il n'était même pas présent
donc un premier nice qui s'est adressé à
l'assemblée sans les représentants du
peuple
en face de lui effectivement en catimini
c'est c'est non seulement être mal élevé
d'une grosse fierté incroyable mais
c'est surtout d'une violence
incommensurable et ont pu ensuite on
divise de temps de parole ils étaient
divisés en commission il est évident
hémicycle et là est encore divisée sur
la motion de censure ça campus on
empêche l'opposition et fiction de
parler et ce qui permet à gilles
legendre lui d'avoir quatre fois plus de
temps et de déballer des mensonges comme
le fait qu'il paye par exemple de
contre-propositions des groupes ce qui
est complètement faux
il y avait des différents groupes des
contre-propositions pour ce système
et oui il y avait des amendements
effectivement qui joue à la virgule on
met une virgule
c'est important parce que si je vous dis
on va manger les enfants on va manger
virgule les enfants ça n'a pas eu tous
mes sens il m'a gêné angers loire
oui a besoin parfois tout faire un
rendement proche mais l'opposition ne
s'en est pas caché un pigeon qu'elle
tentait de faire obstruction est ce que
on peut remettre quand même en cause la
stratégie de l'opposition y compris
quand on est contre cette réforme des
retraites parce qu'elle fournit c'est là
peut être une excuse au gouvernement
pour abréger ses débats en réalité on
peut pas dire qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
annoncé qu'ils allaient faire de
l'obstruction
ils ont annoncé qu'ils allaient faire de
l'obstruction pour obtenir un mois
supplémentaire
c'est très différent donc ils ont dit et
fait dit on va déposer trouve un nombre
d'amendements pour un mois parce qu'on
veut un mois supplémentaire c'est pas du
tout la même chose
et donc ils vont son couple la phrase
bon elle
le sens tout à fait le même et puis
surtout la réalité c'est quand vous
parliez que les gendarmes devant
l'assemblée nationale
samedi soir ils sont mobilisés depuis
dix jours pour être là à l'assemblée
nationale samedi donc il me semble un
peu léger de faire le coup du dernier
moment lors du samedi matin d'un camp
sioniste exceptionnel c'est encore le
virus s'est taillé mais depuis le départ
ce sens avait été annoncée par un
certain nombre de demandes de l'a22 de
l'opposition que de toute façon il
n'était pas en discuter et on l'a aussi
sur la conférence de financement qui
était proposée par la cfdt
et puis en fait assez et on est parti
aujourd'hui en disant n'y a pas de
discussions en fait ils ne sont pas
majoritaires en france mais il ya
peut-être
voilà des français qu'ils n'étaient pas
contre cette réforme est ce que selon en
fin de séance hôtesses de leur point de
vue est ce que c'était pas finalement
assez malin comme stratégie de la part
d' edouard philippe de faire passer ce
projet emmanuel macron qui pourra se
targuer d'être allé au bout de sa
réforme au moment des élections est ce
que ça peut être envisageable que ça
soit une bonne stratégie finalement en
fait c'est une bonne stratégie s'il
assume la violence bien entendu qu'il
assume sa violence dans la rue dans les
maux quotidiens l'étranger qui parlait
français et y la réforme est nécessaire
la réforme des retraites est nécessaire
personne ne dit le contraire
elle est certainement parce qu'il est
intolérable que les femmes soient
décrochés par rapport aux hommes de
tabarez à fait intolérable par contre
n'est pas nécessaire pour le financement
ça c'est faux par exemple nulle part on
mentionne la kadey ce qu'est la caisse
d'amortissement des excédents sociaux
qui était créée par joss stone qui va
dégager à partir de 2024 24 milliards
par an donc le corps 48 milliard de
déficit tout est donc ya pas besoin de
financement pour les retraites les
retraites sont équilibrés sont
excédentaires
il ya 130 milliards d'excédents elles
sont excédentaires ça on ne le dit nulle
part
les retraites sont non seulement elle
dit nulle part en deuxième conférence de
financement et edouard philippe a déjà
prévenu que si ça se passait mal il
ferait à sa manière avec life pivot or
la fo et la cgt aujourd'hui ont claqué
la porte à ce que là encore on doit
craindre un passage en force de l'âge et
rayonnants
on est dans la violence et puis encore
vous savez stéphanie ce qui n'a prononcé
que le texte en 49 3 mais pas celui qui
était débattu à l'assemblée
c'est important dire que il dépose un
vote sans les ans et oui ou non au sinon
on démissionne
sur l'ensemble d'un texte n'a pas été la
belgique ce n'est pas le même temps
ce que je sais pas ce que c'était deux
textes à l'assemblée à 49,3 ne peut être
que sur un seul texte c'est pas le même
il ya sept nouveaux nouveaux articles
qu'ils y sont apparus comme par magie
dans la matinée du 7 dont des questions
qui n'étaient ok vous n'avez pas répondu
donc tout cela était bien calibré ce
texte est écrit depuis très longtemps
ils vont pas de croire que ces articles
ils ont écrit dans la nuit ce n'est pas
vrai il tente de le faire foirer doit
filippis qui dit on a tenu compte voilà
des amendements notamment et puis de ce
qui avait été négociée avec les
partenaires sociaux est ce qu'il ya un
fond égalité ont pas dû bien sûr d'eux
dont ils ont intégré les amendements de
la majorité
oui de la majorité ils n'ont même pas
écouté les amendements de l'opposition
ils ont intégré effectivement des
discussions pour effectuer des parties
edouard philippe mais aussi
voilà des rendez compte les partenaires
sociaux n'ont pas de légitimité en fait
ils se pointent ils sont pas élus il
sépare le manque est légitime ils ont
mis dans une loi quelque chose qui n'a
pas été discuté au parlement
et puis encore une fois sept nouveaux
articles sept nouveaux articles qui
étaient des blancs en disant qu'il sait
être réglé par ordonnance au plus tard
il ya vingt-huit blanc dans une loi vous
imaginez que vous nous présente une loin
dans lequel on ne sait pas comment
commencer calculer comment ça va être
financé comment ça va vivre et et
comment ça va être géré la sarthe il met
alors à priori et enfin le medef ait pas
d'accord le conseil d'état n'est pas
d'accord mais imaginez c'est que qui est
d'accord pour cette paix en fait c'est
bien cette réforme c'est le fond du
problème
il semble que les français d'après les
sondages ne sont pas d'accord
majoritairement les organisations
syndicales ne sont pas d'accord le
conseil d'état elle medef ne sont pas
d'accord ce sont pas on ne parle pas de
bolchévique 1re normalement au medef
et ils ne sont pas d'accord au conseil
d'état et pour autant ils forcent à 49 3
c'est extrêmement violent c'est
extrêmement violent mais comme encore
une fois on tire sur les manifestants
donc qu'à peut-il se passait maintenant
c'est plié ou encore l'espoir pour les
opposants cette réforme qu'elle soit
elle ne soit pas mise en vigueur il ya
des défections déjà il faut vote d'une
motion de censure en voir ce que ça
donne
il ya peu de chance oui il ya pas de
chance j'attends c'est confus peut avoir
une surprise ce soir
non mais mais le modem par contre a très
bien joué parce qu'ils vont récupérer
plein de mairie ils vont récupérer plein
de postes parce qu'avec les 48 du modem
et je les vends ses équipiers de pascal
majorité se délite tous les jours y en
ait plus d qui part il ya les sénateurs
qui quitte en marche
donc il va hier après le vote au sénat
et là il va être un peu plus un peu plus
mal accueilli je pense merci beaucoup
ludovic à erchin expert en communication
auteur d'un documentaire sur le projet
de réforme des retraites
plus de 200 4 en france 2 coronavirus
l'épidémie se propage à travers le pays
un quatrième décès a été enregistré
aujourd'hui les autorités se préparent à
une nouvelle intensification de
l'épidémie mais le maquereau un étang en
visite au centre de crise du ministère
de la santé qui a déclaré ce matin
débloquer 260 millions d'euros dettes
pour les hôpitaux
dans cette période que nous vivons et
que nous allons vivre parce que nous
sommes entrés dans une phase qui va
durer des semaines et même sans doute
des mois il est indispensable d'avoir la
clarté la résilience le sang-froid et la
détermination pour freiner d'abord
l'épidémie ce que nous sommes en train
de faire puis lutter contre celle-ci
nous devons tous avoir conscience que
nous sommes et serons mobilisés dans la
durée mais nous sommes prêts et je sais
que nous aurons cette force de relever
ce défi et premier mort en espagne c'est
ce qu'on apprend ce soir la france reste
l'un des principaux foyers du virus en
europe avec l'allemagne et l'italie
italie qui en régissent 27 nouveaux
décès depuis hier soir soit un total de
79 morts
ailleurs dans le monde la corée du sud
deuxième pays le plus touché après la
chine recense près de 5000 15 28 morts
l'iran annonce de son côté 11 nouveaux
décès milan total 77 morts six décès
également aux états unis où le vice
président mike pence annonce qu'un
traitement entre le virus pourrait être
disponible d'ici à l'été et le kobe 19
chamboule-tout économie mondiale
rencontre internationale jusqu'au prix
du pétrole une réunion de l'opep est
prévue ce jeudi afin de répondre aux
enjeux en pleine épidémie les détails de
notre correspondant à moscou antoine
claireaux chute du tourisme baisse du
trafic aérien
annulation d'événements sportifs ou
encore volatilité des marchés financiers
la propagation du coronavirus à travers
le monde touche bien des secteurs la
production pétrolière en fait clairement
partie
en effet en raison du ralentissement
économique la demande en or noir s'est
elle aussi érodé sera donc l'un des
sujets de discussion au menu de la
réunion de l'opep prévue ce jeudi à
vienne
l'objectif étant pour l'organisation de
réduire la production pour faire
repartir le prix du baril à la hausse
l'arabie saoudite de facto leader de
l'opep militent pour cette solution
le royaume souhaiterait que les pays
producteurs dont fait partie la russie
réduisent au total d'un million de
barils supplémentaires leur production
quotidienne en réponse à l'épidémie
un montant nettement supérieur aux 600
mille barils évoqué dans un premier
temps mais moscou allié important du
cartel pourrait se contenter d'un statu
quo justement ce dimanche une réunion
ministérielle convoquée par vladimir
poutine s'est tenue sur le sujet je
tiens à souligner que pour le début de
la russie pour notre économie
le niveau actuel des prix du pétrole est
acceptable nos réserves accumulées y
compris le fonds national
d'investissement sont suffisantes pour
assurer une situation stable le respect
de tous les engagements budgétaires et
sociaux même en cas de détérioration de
l'économie montrent que la situation
actuelle semble tendre quelque peu
l'arabie saoudite
il s'est même murmurait que ryad
pourrait dénoncé l'entente pétrolières
avec moscou mais cette rumeur a
cependant été bien vite démenties
c'est absurde et totalement insensé nous
avons tous signé la charte de l'opep
plus et continueront d'agir de manière
collective
nous sommes en contact et dialogue
constant avec tous nos partenaires de
l'opep et de l'opep plus
même si la vie des russes venaient à
diverger de celui des saoudiens les
relations bilatérales seraient toujours
excellentes en croire le ministre russe
de l'énergie
nous sommes très satisfaits de la
coopération avec nos partenaires
saoudiens nous voulons poursuivre notre
coopération non seulement au format opep
plus mais aussi dans le cadre des
relations bilatérales
on le sent bien la sphère ne revêt pas
la même importance pour les deux
partenaires
et c'est sans doute les chiffres qui le
prouve le mieux l'arabie saoudite
fortement dépendante de ses exportations
énergétiques a besoin d'un baril à 83
dollars pour que son budget soit à
l'équilibré
la russie pour sa part a fait des
efforts ces dernières années pour
réduire sa dépendance au pétrole et n'a
besoin pour l'exercice 2009 1 que d'un
baril à 42,40 dollars soit pratiquement
moitié moins avec un prix du baril qui
oscille actuellement autour des 50
dollars
on comprend alors que les enjeux ne sont
effectivement pas les mêmes pour ryad et
moscou
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
camille sari économise président de
l'institut euro maghrébin d'étude et de
prospective bonsoir camille sari on l'a
vu dans ce sujet en prochaine réunion de
l'opep jeudi vendredi à vienne la
demande en pétrole risquent de continuer
à abaisser faso coronavirus quelles
conséquences selon vous mais les
conséquences sont dramatiques pour les
pays
mono exportateurs comme les pays de
l'opep essentiellement l'arabie saoudite
le veut le qatar il qui exportent
beaucoup de gaz enfin les émirats et
cetera
ce sont des économies peu diversifiée
qui ont des problèmes aussi de 2
d'évolution démographique et de de
budget de défense qui sont très élevés
je prends l'exemple aussi de l'algérie
dans le même cas alors que la russie a
un coût de production inférieurs déjà
par rapport à d'autres pays
inférieure du point de vue de
l'exploitation et c'est une économie qui
qui a toujours été industriel qui a qui
est diversifiée et qui dispose aussi
d'autres matières premières et d'autres
ressources
ceci étant
tous les pays sans exception
exportateurs de pétrole
à mon avis moi je les dis à un mois
quand les marchés étaient au plus haut
j'avais alerté sur le fait que les
autorités chinoises ne disent pas la
vérité sur le les victimes réelles le
nombre de victimes réelles et on a vu
comment les iraniens qui se déplaçait
beaucoup chine ont été contaminées qu'au
prix des hauts responsables ils ont les
iraniens qui voyagent dans toute la
région et qui aussi des milices qui qui
rentrent plus ou moins clandestinement
en irak au yémen et en syrie
ils ont trop avinés toute la région et
le coût pour l'arabie saoudite c'est
l'annulation de du pèlerinage de la omra
peut-être même deux
le grand pèlerinage c'est une perte
vraiment qui se chiffrent à plusieurs
millions peut-être même plusieurs
milliards l'essentiel dans cette crise
ce n'est pas tant les victimes qu'il
faut déplorer
chacun d'entre nous pourraient être
concernés ou dans sa famille c'est pas
ça le saas est important mais c'est
aussi les précautions prises parce que
il ya un principe de précaution qui dit
que si un risque il faut annuler telle
ou telle manifestation en france ont
annulé une journée donc du salon de
l'agriculture qui malgré sa queue et
puis on voit dans beaucoup de pays
l'annulation du salon de l'auto moderne
au jeu genève aux femmes et puis sur
radio millions et des millions de pertes
effectivement on est et surtout ce qu'il
faut déplorer et ça aussi le marché de
pétroliers stéphanie c'est un marché
spéculatif c c'est à dire les têtes la
confiance est majeur voilà cette affaire
c'est pas on n'achète pas et envoie pas
le pétrole pour le consommer au dos la
majeure partie des cas c'est à dire
c'est une matière que vous vous pouvez
achetez moi aussi je jette
j'achète ça à terme et je revault avec
un bénéfice mais des fois ça peut être
une perte
donc c'est très spéculatif qu'au marché
mais le fond du fossé que l'économie
réelle et c'est ça qui est très
important c'est que ça qui n a pas été
pris en compte par les marchés
financiers les marchés du pétrole et
l'ensemble des acteurs et même des
responsables économiques
c'est que l'économie réelle elle va
souffrir elle souffre déjà
savez vous que la chine contrairement à
2003 la chine c'est un
occupe 30 % des biens intermédiaires
c'est à dire les produits semi finis
destinés à l'industrie mondiale les
midis cabot les produits les pièces il
ya des des iphone qui ne peuvent plus
être fabriquée parce qu'il ose des
pièces qui viennent de chine
à l'heure actuelle les portes à l'art
est quasiment en chine
c'est à dire que les bateaux qui sont
partis il ya quelques mois ils sont
arrivés les enfants de se rendre compte
qu'on est trop dépendant de la chine et
de change est peut-être ce modèle mais
absolument c'est ce que c'est mon
plaidoyer depuis longtemps et je les
écris parce que la chine j'ai eu la
chance ou l'opportunité de voyager en
chine depuis 1992
j'ai vu comment tout les industriels
américains européens et se sont
précipités au chili pour acheter des
marchandises et pour délocaliser
il n'y avait pas une zone industrielle
que j'ai pas visiter il n'y a pas
d'industrie et ils sont très dépendants
l'allemagne archives dépendantes et
d'autres pays également
et tous ces pays là ils ont délocalisé
maintenant ils sont vraiment coincé
c'est à dire que l'économie mondiale
ll est dépendante actuellement de la
chine de l'inde ou la chine représente
25% du pib mondial
les industries chinoises sont en parc du
sinn du monde ça me pardonnez moi de
vous couper il reste peu de temps ça
veut dire qu'on doit vraiment selon vous
selon l'économiste que vous êtes
s'inquiéter aujourd'hui clairement des
conséquences économiques de cette crise
du j'ai ce problème
depuis amoureux et rapide dans un mois
je suis vraiment donne dans l'embarras
de dire que ça va être pire que ce que
nous avons actuellement c'est à dire que
ça va il y aura une paralysie des
activités que ce soit en europe ou aux
états unis peuvent plus le le virus
il s'est en plus on va fermer des
centres commerciaux des usines il ya
déjà beaucoup de pme qui ont fermé des
pme que ce soit en europe ou aux états
unis les états unis et les chiens trompe
été critiqué sur la vérité des chiffres
et puis c'est pas par là par une
injection de liquidités ou par une
baisse des taux d'intérêt à deux d'un
demi point que l'économie mondiale va
être relancé il faut revenir à
l'économie réelle ces paroles
pessimistes qu on se quitte merci
camille sari rester avec nous dans
quelques instants notre débat sur le
super tuesday ce soir jour extrêmement
important pour les démocrates notamment
verra les enjeux et tout et tout mais
voilà je me dépêche
dans quelques secondes astérix
[Musique]
c'est le sentiment que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement a besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes qui poussent le fait de
vivre avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
commune comme une machine un organisme
pour fait partie de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps qu'on vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres mais je pense que
ces gens de projets qui se fait pas tout
seul dans son coin on est dans un truc
vraiment de coopération de partage de
partage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ténor 30 soyez les bienvenus en direct
sur rt france si vous nous rejoignez
ouverture des primaires démocrates
américaine 14 états qui votent lors de
ce scrutin faisait étape déterminante
pour départager le favori bernie sanders
et joe biden notamment l'ancien vice
président a le vent en poupe après avoir
assemblé le camp modéré dans la course à
la maison blanche
derrière la lutte est intense pour
passer la barre des 15% et obtenir des
supers délégué et à paris également au
vote pour au super tuesday les
précisions de notre reporter katia
technique dans le 7e arrondissement de
paris
c'est le super tuesday étape cruciale
pour les primaires démocrates américaine
14 étapes ont voté comme le colorado le
texas ou encore la californie ainsi que
les îles samoa et puis un seizième
scrutin les américains de l'étranger ici
à paris à l'église américaine ce sont
les américains de france qui vont voter
pour le premier jour ils ont jusqu'au 10
mars
ils se sont pressés aujourd'hui dans ce
bâtiment pour désigner un candidat
démocrate
il y a encore cinq candidats en lice
deux fois la course en tête tout d'abord
bernie sanders le favori des sondages le
très social qui se bat pour la sécurité
sociale il est crédité de 29%
d'intentions de vote derrière lui joe
biden l'ancien vice-président de barack
obama
c'est lui le favori du parti mais il
n'est crédité que de 17% d'intentions de
vote est encore derrière michael
vineberg avec 15% malgré
des frais de campagne exorbitants 400
millions juste en frais de campagne
ici donc je vous disais les électeurs
américains sont nombreux et ils veulent
absolument que berck donald trump perdre
les prochaines élections je vous propose
de les écouter
oui pour moi c'est très important de
voter pour
ban vous êtes très important de voter tu
cours mais surtout pour les idées qu'on
a déjà en france on a déjà les choses
comme la sécurité sociale on a déjà une
université qui coûte pas très cher donc
pour moi c'est très important même si on
habite à l'étranger de l'étranger de
voter pour
pour améliorer le pays même si on n'y
habitent pas on paie toujours les impôts
en tant qu'américain donc c'est toujours
très important de le faire partie de 2,2
tout ça et de voter quand on peut cette
élection est tellement importante c'est
des enjeux énormes
d'habitude je vote toujours mais je suis
moins engagés et là je veux vraiment
participer je veux vraiment sentir les
autres je veux j'ai la foi a je pense
que c'est 70% des américains sans pour
la sécurité sociale
mais on a peur de ce mot socialiste
communiste et mais c'est vraiment pas le
cas il ya beaucoup d'américains surtout
les jeunes qui savent que en fait c'est
pas très différent ce camp-là en europe
et pour eux pour nous c'est très
important de 2
de voter pour pouvoir dire que c'est
notre pays et qu'on veut ça et on ne
veut pas mourir parce qu'on est pauvre
où on veut avoir des aides sociales
alors quels sont les enjeux pour les
candidats démocrates à l'investiture
présidentielle bernie sanders petit
conforter son avance sur joe biden ou
est il en danger quel candidat peut
tirer son épingle du jeu c'est l'objet
de notre face à face ce soir et pour en
parler nous sommes avec pèlerine
présidents des républiques enscene
friends bonsoir apolline merci d'être
avec nous ce jour important pour vous on
imagine jean eric branaa spécialisés les
états unis de conférences à l'université
assas paris 2 bonsoir merci également à
vous d'être avec nous pauline juste pour
savoir vous regarder ça avec une
certaine fébrilité ou une simple
curiosité en tant que républicain qui
veut et est sûr de gagner vous nous
l'avez déjà dit non mais là je votais
vous allez regarder ça avec quel oeil ce
soir oui curiaces était bien sûr c'est
important c'est le super mad et mardi
c'est le primaire de jour le plus
important pendant pour les démos cas les
primaires démocrates
et maintenant tout a changé parce
qu'avant c'était que pénis 1 200 têtes
et maintenant tueur bayenet est revenu
de la mort on peut dire son compagnon
étaient presque morts et après le caire
nid du sud
maintenant c'est très serré donc jo bein
peuvent même gagner
de plus elle était dévote ce soit donc
ça serait ça change tout genre avec
branagh c'est la magie de ces primaires
démocrates à mort pourrait susciter
d'ailleurs cette journée donne qui dit
l'important c'est toujours de se relever
et a réussi en tout cas ce pari oui moi
je n'ai pas vu très mort je crois qu'il
faut quand même faire présent gardé la
nuit
mais en réalité on a un narratif le
narratif qui dit que après l'iowa on
regarde les résultats alors que la loi
est un tout petit et à trois millions de
personnes qui représentent pas grand
chose le new hampshire
un million de personnes c'est encore
plus petit et et le nevada commencé à me
donner une indication ce qui pouvait se
passer effectivement parce que c'était
plus important dans l'amérique profonde
et diverses mais la caroline du sud est
venu remettre les pendules à l'heure et
ce soir elles vont être vraiment à
l'heure puisque pour le coup on va avoir
l'ensemble de l'amérique de toutes les
diversités qui vont être présentés
donc c'est vrai que là on en a une vraie
une vraie photographie il est majeur
sans l'être en réalité oui puisque un
tiers des délégués
il faut gagner des délégués pour pouvoir
avoir l'investiture 1991
mais le maintien délégués vont être
distribués mais en réalité derrière il
ya encore un autre supporter usd mardi
prochain et encore un autre le mardi
d'après avec des grands états le
michigan la semaine prochaine la floride
la fois d'après et s'ils sont pas très
loin l'un de l'autre je parle de bernie
sanders et joe biden en réalité dans les
2 mardi qu'ils vont venir c'est très
favorable à à dubaï donne parce que on
va avoir beaucoup d'états dans le sud
est juste ou dans quinze jours avec la
floride où il y aura une très grosse
timbale et là où ou thunder n'a
quasiment aucune chance
historiquement qu'est ce que ça dit ce
super tuesday
on peut presque connaître déjà le visage
qui se dessine tout doucement du
prochain candidat démocrate on s'est un
petit peu prématuré de dire ça non c'est
pas vraiment prématuré
à chaque fois su perthus comme
jean-marie kaddes il y aura des
autrement dit mais jamais une super
tuesday avec 13 14 d'état et surtout
avec la californie le texas en même
temps oui exactement californie avant ce
style 1er ri à nec californie et dont le
3 mars super tuesday
il a voulu d'avoir plus d'impact sur les
primaires donc il y aura d autres jours
mais avec quatre ou cinq états plus
petits avec une très grand que new york
floride où monsieur mais jamais et
encore comme ce soit et deux constats
sont californie qui a plus de 400 elle
est déléguée à gagner et après taxes
plus de 200 d'angré deux très importants
justement on va s'arrêter quelques
instants sur le texas un fief on peut
lire des républicains depuis maintenant
plus de trente ans l'occasion pour les
démocrates peuvent être de prendre de
l'avancé face aux républicains de trump
en novembre prochain le texas qui risque
peut-être de bouleverser les forces
politiques américaines samedi martin
un pari fou qui pourrait faire basculer
les résultats de la présidentielle
ce super tuesday devient un enjeu
primordial dans l'échiquier politique
autant pour les républicains que pour
les démocrates l'enjeu du texas deuxième
état le plus peuplé des états unis fief
des républicains depuis les années 80
fait de l'oeil aux candidats démocrates
alors que l'état n'a pas voté pour un
prétendant démocrate à la présidence
depuis 1976 le nouveau visage
démographique du texas qui a vu sa
population latino américaine triplé en
une génération risque de rabattre les
cartes
beaucoup de gens disent que le texte
c'est un état rouge mais c'est faux et
un état où les gens ne votent pas c'est
pourquoi nous voulons nous assurer que
nous touchons le plus de joueurs
possibles est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles nous avons décidé d'organiser
une tournée et d'entrer en contact avec
ces communautés qui ne sont
habituellement pas touchés par les
campagnes les jeunes électeurs latinos
sont le futur donc seulement du texas
mais des états unis dans ce pays toutes
les 30 secondes un latino fête ses 18
ans dans les dix prochaines années
nous deviendrons la majorité de la
population du pays il est impératif que
tout candidat qui cherche à gagner
commence à donner la priorité à cet
électorat
si les démocrates réussissent à arracher
en novembre prochain l'état à donald
trump
cela risquerait bien de mettre en
difficulté le président jusqu'à leur
confiant une inquiétude partagée par les
républicains si on perd le texas nous
n'aurons plus jamais de président
républicain de notre vivant
si le tarn county tombe le texas tombe
et si le texas tombe
adieu donald trump les résultats du
texas pourrait bien être la grande
surprise de l'élection présidentielle
l'état ne serait plus essentiellement
rouge couleur des républicains mais
pourrait devenir un métissage politique
tirant sur le bleu des démocrates
seraient pas le ring en a vu ses
inquiétudes ses propos alarmistes un des
républicains si le texas tombe on aura
plus donald trump
et plus de républicains de notre vivant
vous partager ses inquiétudes non non je
n'ai aucune inquiétude pour l'élection
générale je vous parle du texas là ses
propos assez haut rédhibitoire sur le
thème relations père le texas il est
républicain perdent le texas un donald
trump
oui maintenant non non je n'ai pas peur
de perdre le texte ce texte c'est s'est
pas complètement rouge comme maladie
mais ces textes quand même un soutien
très fort a dans notre top mais taxer
c'est très important pour le primaire et
je crois que bynum for science a gagné
bruni sein de tutos californie est en
avance en californie mais je crois que
bynum chance à gagner texte tant que ça
ça très intéressant
jean-eric votre mail votre réaction
je suis beaucoup plus mesurée que paul
là dessus effectivement le texas est en
pleine mutation actuellement d'abord en
ce moment il ya un recensement et on
sait qu'à la fin de ce renforcement 1,5
cette année le texas qui a gagné
effectivement beaucoup d'habits
d'habitants va avoir beaucoup de
représentants plémentaires trois
exactement ça veut dire qu'on va
redistribuer les circonscription
redécoupée aux états unis et cette
différence cette redistribution va va se
faire au détriment des des républicains
parce qu'effectivement ces
circonscriptions s'agrandissent parce
que nombre d'habitants qui est englobé à
s'agrandit et ça profite aux démocrates
il est vrai aussi que les hispaniques
qui ne votent pas là dessus je suis
assez d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
commence quand même à aller vers le
le bulletin de vote et à l'occasion de
cette élection il pourrait bien y avoir
un mouvement qui fait qu'ils
s'inscrivent davantage parce qu'il ya un
rejet de donald trump qui est très très
fort alors peut-être que ça donnera pas
un résultat tout de suite sur 2020 mais
en tout cas sur 2024 ou 2028 le texas
effectivement devrait basculer
et quand li na rézon le jour où le texas
bascule parce qu'il ya 38 grands
électeurs et bien c'est très difficile
pour les républicains de pouvoir penser
à avoir un président c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que george w bush
pardon jeff bush à la dernière fois
expliqué qu'il fallait se pencher vers
le vote hispanique et essayer de séduire
les hispaniques lui qui est du texas qui
était qui est marié à une mexicaine et
c'était la stratégie de parti
républicain avant que trains n'arrivent
parle de son mur parle de ce rejet des
hispaniques et il ya une vraie coupure
aujourd'hui entre le parti républicain
et cette population si je peux dire oui
on parle jamais que de l'est les
pressantes âge des hispaniques aux états
unis qui soutient des actions maintenant
donc non il peut parler ces derniers
temps avec justement ces bons résultats
économiques et puis elle est mise pour
les minorités de trouver du travail ils
en font partie oui exactement à ta en
tuant pas c'est pas que les hispaniques
l'unicef aux efforts américains aussi il
a gagné moins de 10% des f&a franken en
2016 et maintenant il ya plus de 20% qui
soutient dans mon champ d'onal et si
part du fardeau des hispaniques les
arbalètes c'était c'était vers 20% qu'il
a gagné maintenant l'assurance ont dansé
c'est plus que ça c'est entre 20 et 30%
à mermoz bien sûr de laisser mais si
c'était ça il aurait aucun problème pour
se faire élire mais on en n'est
effectivement pas à des chiffres comme
ça
le pourcentage de 10 panique qui
soutient donald trump est toujours aussi
bas il n'a pas bougé depuis son élection
non et concernant les afro américains
ont sonné à 9% on est passé de 21 à 9 1
% 20 % ce serait un chiffre
extraordinaire
c'est un peu comme bernie sanders qui
expliqué qu'ils étaient soutenus par la
communauté noire
rouch mais c'est que ça donne ça c'est
une projection vers à gori et à une
amende et hispanique aux états unis qui
sont sont plus stables avec l'économie
ils ont fait le boulot
ils sont en colère avec cette
institution du talentueux mais vous
verrez que juste parce qu'il ya des
hispaniques en taxi ça ne dira pas que
les hispaniques va à voter pour les
démocrates
alors on le disait dans 14 états qui
votent en même temps
des étapes différentes et que ça s'en
vient d'en parler californien on a un
peu parlé mais ses shoots 7 alabama vous
avez commencé tout à l'heure à faire
cette analyse mais ce que ça reflète
vraiment la diversité sociale et
économique du pays est ce que ça donne
une bonne photographie de ce que sont
les états unis aujourd'hui jean eric
branaa oui absolument d'abord on a les
états du sud alors c'est réel très
éclectique on passe par le l'oklahoma
l'alabama le texas on en a dit on en a
parlé l'arkansas mais on monte jusqu'au
minnesota donc on est au nord des états
unis on va de l'autre côté à l'est
connectique vermeil massachusetts et à
l'ouest on à l'ugta le colorado et la
californie comment voulez-vous faire
plus diversifiée on a tous les coins des
états unis en réalité toutes les
populations donc c'est vrai que la
photographie la photographie qu'on va
voir demain matin va être extraordinaire
parce que c'est à peu près la
photographie qui se reproduira à peu
près partout
après effectivement avec des forces
différentes suivant les uns et les
autres
alors parlons des protagonistes
effectivement bernie sanders qui avait
longtemps enfin longtemps on sent de
parler mais enfin en tout cas qui fait
la course en tête dans les sondages mais
joe biden qui semble vous l'avais dit à
le rattraper avec la victoire en
caroline du sud vous en tant que
républicain vous êtes perrier qui
justement
demandez aux questions est oui mais qui
vous fait le plus peur finalement face à
donald trump en novembre c'est difficile
à dire pour moi je voudrais vraiment
voir il n'a une course de socialisme
compte capitalisme tom pernice en
bénissant de contredanses jean pellez
vrai débat parce qu'il y a c'est vrai
que bruni siens 2-1 en gros une petite
armée d surtout les jeunes les jeunes
qui croient que les choses et il croit
que les idées de socialistes sont très
bien ça vous étonne justement ces jeunes
qui soutiennent farouchement bernie
sanders qui est quand même pas
effectivement le plus peut-être le plus
fringant de tous les candidats
c'est étonnant selon vous c'est
maintenant en attendant pour moi parce
que en termes de qu'il soutient
socialisme parce que les professeurs
d'université il pousse cette idée que
socialisme et plus du gouvernement ces
mairies des capitalismes sait les
problèmes dans le monde et c'est mai
donc je suis pas surpris mais à je suis
pas sûr que bernie va gagner maintenant
avec ce style c'est pas juste populaire
de dubaï mais c'est le parti est très
divisée entre deux entre modérerait si
on peut dire je crois pas qu'il ya des
vrais demanderai dans le parti
démocratique démocrates mais le modéré
et l'extrême gauche et les mots dray et
il haïra excuses on peut prendre tout le
temps mais grâce à les gens qui sont
vient d'arrêter le convaincant meilleur
picqué et émir crochet par exemple on
vient de menace heures de temps qu'un
soutien d'un bail de don payne a
probablement gagné mais ne soldent donc
c'est très divisée en ce moment dans le
prime un grand chance à gagner donc on
verra
jean eric branaa parler de bernie
sanders d'abord est un autoproclamé
socialiste puisqu'il est pas très
socialiste non plus
compareriez acquis par exemple en france
quelle ligne parce qu'alors paul ring
nous parler d'extrême gauche face à ces
soirées jean-luc mélenchon ex-ps
mélenchon ça va ça va même trop loin par
rapport à ce qui est bernie sanders et
est un social démocrate un hymne agnel
6e mais c'est quoi sur de madames cette
social-démocratie accueillir oui même si
je peux les digues et l'extrême gauche
aux états unis est toujours beaucoup
plus à droite il énoncé il est en
réalité il met pas en cause le
capitalisme en tant que tel il s'en
accommode
ce qu'il fait c'est sur le plan sociétal
où il y avait effectivement des carences
très forte un débat qui a eu lieu déjà
en 2016 c'est sur la santé débat qui a
été mal résolu puisque l'obamacare est
toujours là et n'a pas été remplacé par
un plan phénoménal comme nous présenter
donald trump pendant la campagne et
bernie lui prétend avoir un plan
phénoménal qui serait d'offrir à tout le
monde
alors là il se pose le problème du
financement et c'est bien ce que les
républicains vont lire proposez-lui lui
reprocher mais aussi une frange modérée
des démocrates qui vont dire enfin ce
plan là on n'est pas sûr qu'il soit
viable pour tout le monde est ce que à
la fin on va s'en sortir c'est le débat
il va être là dessus il va être vraiment
assez technique assez financiers donc
moi je trouve pas que ce soit le débat
le plus intéressant en réalité si on
oppose l'un à l'autre en réalité avec
joe biden un autre débat c'est de savoir
si les modérés républicains vont rester
du côté de donald trump avec lesquels
ils sont aujourd'hui objectivement alors
qu'il n'y avait pas il ya encore un an
mais aujourd'hui objectivement oui mais
s'ils ont une autre offre qui est
modérée et acceptable pour eux ça serai
quoi ils donnent un temps et donne et en
république incompatibles on va le dire
ainsi puisque hommes du compromis de
l'histoire américaine ça fait 36 ans de
sénateur + mi-temps de vice présidence
c'est un homme qui l on s'est habitué
les républicains le connaissent aussi
et là ça ça gênerait donald trump qui
auraient du mal à pouvoir attaquer cet
homme l'avait qu'elle ya assez peu de
prise mise à part s'attaquer sur son
caractère sa personnalité son bégaiement
ses gaffes mais voyez on est à la marge
en réalité c'est pas ça
il va bouleverser l'amérique sur sur la
gestion au quotidien et donc les
américains pourraient répondre à cette
offre là c'est plutôt ça qu'ils
remettraient donald trump d'ailleurs
depuis qu ils remontent comme dit saint
paul depuis 48 heures on voit que les
attaques contre donald 3 1 pour repris
de plus belle à la fois de la part de
donald trump lui même mais aussi de
toute son armée parce qu'il a une grosse
armée lui aussi y'a pas de bernie
sanders et cette armée sur les réseaux
sociaux meilleur ratio à 6 il ya même
une armée il ya ma main s'il ya même un
site qui s'appelle tram sont remis dans
lequel les en demande
non je pars de 30 ha ha excuse moi les
autres à un prix bien cette arme est là
et déjà tué des gens ils attaquent
hebeisen en sentant que le danger est
beaucoup plus grand avec lui il n'y a
pas beaucoup prise jean eric branaa a
raison a pas leur hymne pas beaucoup de
prise finalement contre joe biden il est
peu critiquables et critiquées
jobs a noté le vice président d'obama
pendant huit ans et un ans maman choses
à critiquer la sueur tu sais ces
résultats dans les affaires étrangères
était horrible et a rien fait de bien
il est dur bannit pas fort mais il n'est
pas fort et et en séries l'on y avait
des attaques chimiques en série
qu'est-ce que bein obama fait 0 ils ont
déclenché une guerre en libye
après l'ambassadeur été tués tu es au
bail un buy in était le vice président
et avait cet accord sont avec iron son
accord avec le congrès américain un
désastre la russe la russe a attaqué à
comines
l'attaqué la russie envahi ukraine
pendant le vice-président de bredene
donc il ya plein de choses là et il peut
pas dire que il est très expérimenté et
a beaucoup de succès il n'a pas de
succès et donc il ya plein champ
j'aimerais bien devoir de bar entre
trempé gbagbo on l'a vite enterré lui
aussi avec son son premier débat louper
il n'empêche pas ce qu'il pourrait
servir d'arbitré michael bloomberg pour
ces primaires démocrates
c'est ce qu'on attend en réalité demain
matin on va avoir une information qu'on
n'a pas un n'est pas en mesure de donner
aujourd'hui puisqu'on ne sait absolument
pas ce que peut donner bloomberg rendez
vous compte 500 millions de dollars de
dépenser une somme au j'arrive même pas
l'imaginer tellement et l'ailier est
énorme et cet argent peut-être n'aura
servi à rien et pourquoi est ce que je
dis ça parce qu'on avait déjà un autre
milliardaire tome ce tailleur qui a
dépensé lui 200 millions pour rien il
n'a pas gagné un seul délégué est ce que
c'est la même chose avec bloomberg
on n'en sait rien au moment où on parle
certains sondages nous explique qu'il
est en train de gagner dans certains
états on parle de quatre états sur
lequel il serait très haut notamment
l'ugta et le maine mais également
l'arkansas et l'oklahoma ont pour
l'instant c'est des suppositions les
sondages n'ont pas eu de très bons
résultats jusqu'à aujourd'hui
en tout cas depuis le début de ces
primaires il faut s'en méfier parce
qu'effectivement il ya des phénomènes
qui n'ont pas vu et là ils nous
annoncent peut-être un phénomène qui
s'il s'avérait juste serait énorme parce
qu'effectivement s'il a réussi avec son
argent à s'acheter le ticket pour la
maison blanche il s'est passé quelque
chose aux états unis mais s'il n'a pas
réussi c'est également une information
est elle à ce moment là on souffre avec
une course à deux by john saunders en
tout cas dans quelques heures on sera
fixé palringo justement bloomberg
il ya deux candidats blue bay dans la
course et
toujours dans la chronique de sms de
jeter l'épongé après c'est rien du tout
il ya deux en tête et vraiment c'est une
course à deux donc mais tous les deux
vont gagne s'ils gagnent 15% à 2 les
électeurs voteront chaque état il gagne
pourcentage de les délégués donc c'est
très possible que tous les deux vont
gagner des délégués et ça c'est une
chose chacun
quelqu'un doit gagne majorité de votes
par le prurit et le mesure était peut
être nominé de candidat pour le parti
démocrate
et avec one et bloomberg
c'est juste il va conduire à minimiser
les chances que soit by day nous soient
sains deux vont gagner la majorité et il
y aura une convention juillet contestées
dernière petite question le silence
assourdissant de barack obama c'est
normal c'est de coalition c'est normal
il l'avait annoncé et il l'avait annoncé
il ya déjà un nom en disant qu'il
n'interviendrait pas quoi qu'il arrive
dans ce débat jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient un
nominé à la convention de milwaukee ici
tient je trouve ça plutôt mieux pour les
l'ensemble des candidats il n'y a pas de
raison qu'ils favorisent l'un ou l'autre
il est évident que dans la tête de tout
le monde y favorise davantage byden kate
son vice président avec lequel il est
ami donc encore plus pour cette raison
là je trouve que son silence est assez
classe et qui et j'espère qu'il va s'y
tenir
parce que effectivement la course a
besoin d'être la plus transparente
possible
merci à tous les deux par louis nahi
branagh d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
face à face à ses lapins de cette
émission prochain point sur l'actualité
dans 5 minutes avec ce soir david
khalifa
[Musique]
le pire je pense en tout cas
politiquement pour l'union européenne
c'est que ça se passe bien pour les
anglais et y aura peut-être un effet
boule de neige si l'italie sort vous
avez un éclatement de l'euro et de
l'union européenne dans les mois qui
suivent
l'euro s'est pas seulement un projet
financier c'est un projet politique
hosni l'euro ne fonctionne pas sinon
n'auraient pas lu un seul a eu avec la
grèce je suis partiellement pas d'accord
sur l'échec de l'euro on maintient la
grèce en commun à mon avis c'est une
bonne chose
vous pouvez pas vous réjouir d'avoir
votre pays qui est sous perfusion sous
assistance respiratoire en permanence
[Musique]
au printemps il verra t-on équipements
et le cas sera un morceau when he was t
il prendre à ton âme qui est puis un
festival qui est dit
[Musique]
hmmmm avant il y avait trois chaman
maintenant ils sont beaucoup les
pèlerins ceux qui sont venus pour un
service de prières par là
oh
[Musique]
comment pas te fait de notre pas
seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé à le gêner des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
pourquoi vraiment d'hollywood est née au
nigeria et pas par exemple au sénégal au
mali a tourné un homme d'affaires ont
déjà réagi en homme comme femme tout le
monde et businessman et ça c'est
impressionnant
donc nollywood est là clairement le vent
en poupe et les budgets ce qui est gros
budgets des films à gros budget comme
aux états unis mêmes enfants français
aujourd'hui le record de budget aux
nigériens ses 9 millions de dollars et
monter en gamme
d'un point de vue technique
niveau des histoires racontées et s'est
du coup ça implique effectivement des
budgets beaucoup plus important donc il
ya beaucoup de choses qui se passent
beaucoup de pays francophones notamment
qui regarde ce qu'est ce qu'on dirait
qu'ils apprennent et qui essayent de
de faire pareil
[Musique]
temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à 6 ans il y avait tous ici elle perd le
vertdure de la ville la zone était
habité par plusieurs familles mais
maintenant je vais voir vous même comme
ça
alors au sol de 700 à 1000 familles
seront évacués de force aujourd'hui ou
demain
quelques unes seront jetés dehors
[Musique]
parfois quand je marche sur le char ben
je vois qu'ils fument par endroits mais
dessus ton pied glisse qu'on laisse le
charbon est l'objectif principal
tout le monde veut du charbon les gens
sont traités ici comme des rebuts
[Musique]
le gouvernement face aux deux motions de
censure de la droite et de la gauche
elles sont débattues à l'assemblée
nationale ce soir alors que les
opposants à la réforme était dans la rue
aujourd'hui
ils étaient vingt mille à paris selon
les syndicats
la crise du coronavirus emmanuel macron
évoque une phase qui va durer des
semaines et sans doute des mois
4e morts recensés en france aujourd'hui
sur 212 cas confirmés dans l'hexagone le
président annonce la réquisition des
stocks et de la production des masques
de protection
un conseil de défense et sia dédié au
cours d'un virus aura lieu mercredi
matin la grèce en situation de crise
face à l'afflux de migrants l'union
européenne promet toute l'aide
nécessaire au pays des dizaines de
milliers de personnes ont migré depuis
que le président recep tayyip cardo a
ordonné l'ouverture des frontières de la
turquie et pays membres de l'union
européenne viennent de les leur accord
pour une intervention rapide de frontex
l'agencé européenne de contrôle des
frontières
[Musique]
beaucoup
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue à vous si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france le
recours par le gouvernement aux 49 3
ravive la protestation en france
l'assemblée nationale se penche ce soir
sur les deux motions de censure déposée
par l'opposition de droite et celles de
gauche notre reporter ben hassen chébili
suit les débats on le retrouve tout de
suite
bonsoir bassem alors à quoi faut-il
s'attendre dans l'hémicycle ce soir
à écouter david les discussions ont
commencé depuis 15 heures ici à
l'assemblée nationale après le dépôt de
ces deux motions de censure une par la
gauche et puis une par la droite le
groupe républicain marine le pen aurait
également si cette motion de censure
celle présentée par la gauche
ici à l'assemblée nationale et débat
continue comme je voulais dit une séance
au pendant quelques minutes pour des bas
ces deux motions de censure l'opposition
est bien décidé à barrage à se faire
entendre auprès du goût de suite à ce
passage du 49-3 sur la réforme des
retraites par le gouvernement annoncée
par edouard philippe
le samedi dernier certains députés sont
même monté au pupitre pour pouvoir
défendre cette motion de censure damien
abad le chef de file des républicains a
même déclaré que cette motion de censure
empêcher le débat il a souligné
l'amateurisme de l'amas de la majorité
parlementaire il apparaît aussi d'un
gouvernement qui privilégie ses intérêts
au détriment des intérêts de la france
voilà les réactions étaient nombreuses
on a pu également ont parlé avec
certains députés dont nicolas dupont
aignan qui a parlé d'une nécessité de la
dhr de travail ensemble il a même évoqué
la possibilité de l'organisation d'un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne qui
pourrait être une solution pour lui je
vous propose de l'écouter comme le
premier ministre et le gouvernement ne
peuvent pas répondre aux questions des
parlementaires
eh bien ils passent en force il veut
raccourcir le débat mais je crois que
les français ne seront pas dupes et en
tout cas ce sera donc l'enjeu des
futures élections notamment la
présidentielle pense que tous les
français qui ont compris le cynisme du
gouvernement et surtout la manière dont
il a fait le samedi après avoir fait une
conférence de presse sur le court aux
navires russes enfin tout ça est très
mesquin très petit et vraiment pas à la
hauteur de l'enjeu
là je voterai des deux motions de
censure l'une de droite lutte de gauche
parce que je crois qu'il faut
symboliquement qui est le maximum de
voix mais je pense que l'enjeu mois je
souhaiterais qu'on est plutôt une motion
référendaire
c'est à dire que si la droite et la
gauche s'entendaient pour demander un
référendum d'initiative populaire
qui est d'initiative partagée le terme
technique de la constitution nous
pourrions demander aux français ensuite
de signer d'avoir les 4 millions de
signatures nécessaires à l'obligation
pour le gouvernement de tenir un
référendum je vois que ça comme solution
parce que tout le monde sait que les
motions de censure ne seront pas valable
puisque nous n'avons pas la majorité
après les différentes prises de parole
dans l'hémicycle et des différentes
familles politiques c'était au tour du
chef du gouvernement edouard philippe de
prendre la parole il est monté au
pupitre pour défendre bien sûr cette
réforme des retraites est justifié ce
passage en force grâce aux 49 3 il a
souligné qu'il y avait deux motions
censure idée reconnaît il a même parlé
d'une responsabilité du que chaque parti
devra apprendre le gouvernement est bien
sûr les parlementaires qui ont proposé
cette motion de censure il a également
dit que ces motions de censure
n'empêcheront pas le gouvernement de
réparer le système social français il a
dit qu'une minorité bloquer tout débat
et que ce n'était pas à l'honneur du
débat parlementaire et doit aussi
évoquer des combines procédure à des
intimidations extérieurs et des actes de
violences subies par certains de la
majorité
voilà les mots du premier ministre au
pupitre pour défendre bien sûr cette
réforme des retraites comme je voulais
expliquer et davy les discussions
devaient reprendre dans quelques minutes
une soirée qui cette longue pour deux
dans le cadre de ces deux motions de
censure présentée contre cette réforme
des retraites le passage en force du
gouvernement
merci beaucoup aux bassins chebbi depuis
l'assemblée nationale et pour protester
contre le 49-3 à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale plusieurs
manifestations avaient lieu aujourd'hui
en france plus de 20000 personnes
mobilisées à paris selon les syndicats
des rassemblements également à toulouse
à marseille ou encore à lille le récit
de cette journée avec rana berrada
le rendez vous était donné à 13h30 place
de la république le cortège parisien est
finalement parti vers 14h15 dans les
rangs des manifestants des enseignants
des cheminots mais aussi des avocats
toujours fortement mobilisé contre la
réforme des retraites
le projet constitutionnel sera saisi
il déclarera inconstestablement un
certain nombre de dispositions de ce
texte contraire à la constitution donc
il faut rester mobilisés ce gouvernement
un problème de dialogue
en réalité il a des lubies il porte une
réforme dogmatique il n'a pas de
réponses aux questions qu'on lui pose
notamment sur la valeur du point et donc
ils préfèrent se servir de cette
épidémie pour faire diversion et pas
répondre aux questions fondamentales qui
se posent dans ce projet de loi au
centre des préoccupations des
manifestants le recours aux 49 3 en
pleine épidémie de coronavirus une façon
pour le gouvernement de passer en force
et de faire fi de leurs revendications
regrette les syndicalistes
il faut un conseil des ministres pour
parler du corona puis finalement bas il
nous rajoute de la pression sociale
quand ils nous rajoute une petite chaise
social l'après midi avec le 49-3 donc
c'est pas surprenant en même temps pas
de toute façon 49,3 ou pas c'est le
passage en force
quoi qu'il se passe de 7,2 cette réforme
donc ça change pas le fait que de toute
façon il faut se mobiliser le plus
largement possible
et évidemment il s'agit pas que la
réforme des retraites il s'agit de
mettre en échec toute 1
cette politique libérale qui montre bien
son vrai visage aujourd'hui parmi les
protestataires figuraient également des
élus mobilisés contre le texte
pour la sénatrice esther benbassa la
décision du gouvernement mettant en
péril la démocratie ya eu quand même
enfin un glissement vers une démocratie
autoritaire d'un côté là
la violence des interventions policières
le nombre de blessés le la façon d'agir
à l'endroit des gilets jaunes et de
l'autre côté maintenant on se retrouve
avec un texte qui a été quand même et 10
ont bâillonnés avec le 49-3 le cortège
parisien s'est dispersée vers 17 heures
place de la madeleine où l'attendaient
en important dispositif de sécurité
les protestataires n'ont pas pu accéder
aux abords de l'assemblée nationale
comme prive
l'appel à la mobilisation a également
été suivis en province des milliers de
manifestants se sont rassemblés à
marseille à toulouse à lille ou encore à
bordeaux
écoutez à présent les analyses de
benjamin amar enseignants membres de
l'union départementale cgt 94 et de
caroline mécary avocate
c'est ma roue ce qui à certains
éditorialistes qui s'empressent je
prends pas de personnes dont des
maléfices et les premiers à applaudir
quand il ya par exemple le service
minimum donc bien évidemment quand on
est sur une sur une initiative aussi
réactive bas bien sûr que tout le monde
ne pas se mettre en grève et que encore
une fois c'est des gens qui ne se sont
pas mobilisés sans doute depuis clovis
mais qui n'ont jamais fait grève depuis
vercingétorix mais dont la dans le monde
réel du capitalisme du 21e siècle
oui bien sûr les initiatives sont
fatalement moins massive pour autant il
ya quand même effectivement des dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui se sont
mobilisés alors que la prochaine date de
mobilisation c'est celle du 31 mars
donc bien sûr que le 49-3 scandalise et
ils scandalise ceux qui se sont arrangés
pour être aux grèves et au mali pour
d'huy et bien au delà
nous savons que ce gouvernement est dans
une logique qui est une logique
dogmatique
c'est à dire en ligne de mire les
retraites ne doivent pas peser plus de
14% du pib très bien et donc comme dans
la conférence du financement on a appris
que il n'y aurait absolument aucune
possibilité de discuter sur une
éventuelle augmentation de la cotisation
patronale qui va payer ce sont les
travailleurs qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
dans le public ou dans le privé où que
ce soit des travailleurs indépendants
comment est ce qu'un président peut
imaginer qu'une réforme comme celle des
retraites qui remet en cause l'héritage
du conseil national de la résistance qui
avait quand même pour objet d'instituer
une solidarité entre les actifs et ceux
qui cessent de travailler puissent être
discuté en l'espace de même pas trois
semaines à l'assemblée nationale autre
mobilisation en france aujourd'hui la
vanille pour tout ce qui est descendue
dans les rues de paris en fin de journée
un rassemblement à l'appel du collectif
pour protester contre le projet de loi
un bioéthique nombreux manifestants
étaient présents place clemenceau à
paris une nouvelle action est prévue ce
dimanche contre la pma et la gpa on va
maintenant s'intéresser au corona virus
plus de 200 cas en france l'épidémie se
propage à travers le pays un quatrième
décès a été enregistré
les autorités se préparent à une
nouvelle intensification de l'épidémie
emmanuel macron était en visite au
centre de crise du ministère de la santé
qui a déclaré ce matin à débloquer 260
millions d'euros
dead pour les hôpitaux dans cette
période que nous vivons et que nous
allons vivre parce que nous sommes
rentrés dans une phase qui va durer des
semaines et même sans doute des mois il
est indispensable d'avoir la clarté la
résilience le sang-froid et la
détermination pour freiner d'abord
l'épidémie ce que nous sommes en train
de faire puis lutter contre celle-ci
nous devons tous avoir conscience que
nous sommes et serons mobilisés dans la
durée mais nous sommes prêts et je sais
que nous aurons cette force de relever
ce défi parmi les régions les plus
touchées en france
l'oise la haute savoie ou encore le
morbihan fle ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire assure et qu'il n'y a pas
de risque de pénurie et met en garde
contre la spéculation sur les gels
hydroalcooliques on voit ça avec
françois thiery tx dépistage matinale
pour des élèves du collège jean de la
fontaine de crépy en valois
c'est dans cet établissement scolaire
que l'enseignant de 60 ans décédé du
coronavirus dans la nuit du 25 au 26
février travaillaient là on va faire le
dépistage pour les filles ce que vu
qu'elle était dans la même classe que le
professeur donc on va voir s'il ya
quelque chose mais jusque-là bons mâles
a pas eu de fièvre à l'arrêt a eu donc
on verra bien je pense pas que l ai
attrapé
on nous a convoqués hier j'étais au
travail gérer ses messages
comme quoi il fallait qu'ils amènent à
mon fils et poro les tests et médicale
parce qu'elles le pensent et qui est
décédé c'était son procès des
technologies
dans les magasins de nombreux rayons de
première nécessité ont été pris d'assaut
mais le ministre de l'économie se veut
rassurant il n'y a pas de problème
d'approvisionnement
ni de risque de pénurie il n'y a pas de
pénurie sauf si tout le monde se rue sur
des produits dans les grands magasins et
dans les grandes surfaces
aussi chacun se met à faire des stocks
de riz de pâtes de minéral de fruits de
légumes ou de viande bien entendu qu'il
pourra y avoir de répit du riz mais si
chacun adopte un comportement
responsable et un comportement de
consommation normale et classique vous
acheter ce dont j'ai besoin pour vous
même et pour votre famille soit au jour
le jour je peux de manière hebdomadaire
y a pas de risque de pénurie pas de
pénurie non plus des gels hydro
alcooliques mais bruno le maire met en
garde contre une éventuelle spéculation
un décret pourrait même en fixer le prix
si une augmentation significative et
constater si nous nous apercevons que
par rapport aux prix des gels
hydroalcooliques en petites quantités en
grande quantité qu'ils étaient pratiqués
avant la crise les prix ont doublé
triplé ou quadruplé
nous prendrons les mesures nécessaires
mais nécessaire c'est très simple c'est
un décret qui fixera les prix et qui
interdira toute spéculation sur les prix
des gels hydroalcooliques personne ne
peut accepter qu'il y ait la moindre
spéculation sur la crise du coronavirus
concernant les matches de football et de
rugby prévue ce week end ils ne sont
pour l'instant soumis à aucune
restriction particulière a annoncé la
ministre des sports la situation reste
évolue-t-il précise roxana maracineanu
et chaque manifestation sera étudiée au
cas par cas
premier mort en espagne apprend t-on ce
soir la france reste l'un des principaux
foyers du virus en europe avec
l'allemagne et l'italie l'italie qui
enregistre 27 nouveaux morts depuis hier
soit un total de 79 décès la banque
mondiale a annoncé une aide immédiate de
12 milliards de dollars
ailleurs dans le monde la corée du sud
deuxième pays le plus touché après la
chine recense près de 5000 cas et 28
morts iron annoncent onze nouveaux décès
bilan total de 77 morts
premier cas en argentine et au chili
également neuf décès aux états unis où
le vice président mike pence annonce
qu'un traitement contre le virus
pourraient être disponibles d'ici l'été
en attendant le court aux navires us
impact le monde de manière assez
importante l'économie les rencontres
internationales jusqu'aux prix du
pétrole
une réunion de l'opep est prévue ce
jeudi afin de répondre aux enjeux en
pleine épidémie les détails de notre
correspondant à moscou
antoine clients chute du tourisme baisse
du trafic aérien
annulation d'événements sportifs ou
encore volatilité des marchés financiers
la propagation du coronavirus à travers
le monde touche bien des secteurs la
production pétrolière en fait clairement
partie
en effet en raison du ralentissement
économique la demande en or noir s'est
elle aussi érodé sera donc l'un des
sujets de discussion au menu de la
réunion de l'opep prévue ce jeudi à
vienne
l'objectif étant pour l'organisation de
réduire la production pour faire
repartir le prix du baril à la hausse
l'arabie saoudite de facto leader de
l'opep militent pour cette solution
le royaume souhaiterait que les pays
producteurs dont fait partie la russie
réduisent au total d'un million de
barils supplémentaires leur production
quotidienne en réponse à l'épidémie
un montant nettement supérieur aux 600
mille barils évoqué dans un premier
temps mais moscou allié important du
cartel pourrait se contenter d'un statu
quo justement ce dimanche une réunion
ministérielle convoquée par vladimir
poutine s'est tenue sur le sujet je
tiens à souligner que pour le début de
la russie pour notre économie
le niveau actuel des prix du pétrole est
acceptable nos réserves accumulées y
compris le fonds national
d'investissement sont suffisantes pour
assurer une situation stable le respect
de tous les engagements budgétaires et
sociaux même en cas de détérioration de
l'économie mondiale
la situation actuelle semble tendre
quelque peu l'arabie saoudite
il s'est même murmurait que ryad
pourrait dénoncé l'entente pétrolières
avec moscou mais cette rumeur a
cependant été bien vite démenties
c'est absurde et totalement insensé nous
avons tous signé la charte de l'opep
plus et continueront d'agir de manière
collective
nous sommes en contact et dialogue
temps avec tous nos partenaires de
l'opep et de l'opep plus et même si la
vie des russes venaient à diverger de
celui des saoudiens les relations
bilatérales seraient toujours
excellentes en croire le ministre russe
de l'énergie
nous sommes très satisfaits de la
coopération avec nos partenaires
saoudiens nous voulons poursuivre notre
coopération non seulement au format opep
plus mais aussi dans le cadre des
relations bilatérales
on le sent bien la sphère ne revêt pas
la même importance pour les deux
partenaires
et c'est sans doute les chiffres qui le
prouve le mieux l'arabie saoudite
fortement dépendante de ses exportations
énergétiques a besoin d'un baril à 83
dollars pour que son budget soit à l'
équilibre
la russie pour sa part a fait des
efforts ces dernières années pour
réduire sa dépendance au pétrole et n'a
besoin pour l'exercice 2009 1 que d'un
baril à 42,40 dollars soit pratiquement
moitié moins avec un prix du baril qui
oscille actuellement autour des 50
dollars
on comprend alors que les enjeux ne sont
effectivement pas les mêmes pour ryad et
moscou pour camille sari économiste et
président de l'institut euro maghrébin
d'étude et de prospective la situation
économique risque d'empirer
d'ici les prochains mois je suis
vraiment d'eau dans l'embarras de dire
que ça va être pire que ce que nous
avons actuellement c'est à dire que ça
va il y aura une paralysie des activités
que ce soit en europe ou aux états unis
petit peu plus le virus il s'est en plus
on va fermer des centres commerciaux des
usines il ya déjà beaucoup de pme qui
ont fermé des pme que ce soit en europe
ou aux états unis les états unis et les
chiens trompette est critiqué sur la
vérité des chiffres
et puis c'est pas par là par une
injection de liquidités ou par une
baisse des taux d'intérêt à 2 n 2 bis
poids que l'économie mondiale va être
relancé il faut revenir à l'économie
très
situation alarmante en grèce l'union
européenne promet toute l'aide
nécessaire à athènes dirigeants
européens se sont rendus aujourd'hui en
grèce son objectif aider le pays à faire
face à l'afflux de milliers de migrants
via la turquie d arriver en masse et
depuis que recep tayyip erdogan a ouvert
sa frontière en voit ça avec florian
lambert l'union européenne joue la carte
de la solidarité en grèce alors que des
milliers de migrants sont toujours
stoppés à la frontière gréco turque
les dirigeants européens se réunissent
et ce mardi au poste frontalier de caste
à nice la présidente de l'union
européenne
ursula von der leyen a tenu à affirmer
un soutien total de l'europe à la grèce
dépassé par ce conflit humanitaire les
autorités grecques font face à cette
difficile tâche qui consiste à contenir
cette situation je voudrais remercier
les gardes frontière et les gardes côtes
grecs
je voudrais remercier les civils les
agents et agentes de police et je
voudrais remercier frontex pour la
réaction à fatiguer il est important
pour moi d'être ici avec vous
aujourd'hui et vous dire que
l'appréhension des grecs est aussi la
nôtre
cette frontière n'est pas seulement
grecque mais aussi européenne et à ce
titre je suis ici en tant qu'européenne
un soutien public et matérielles la
présidente de l'union européenne promet
une aide financière de 700 millions
d'euros à athènes afin de répondre aux
enjeux d'une nouvelle vague migratoire à
la demande de la grèce l'agencé
européenne de surveillance des
frontières frontex s'est dite prête à
déployer une force rapide comprenant
notamment un navire de patrouille heures
deux hélicoptères et un avion sans
gardes frontières européens
supplémentaires seront déployés
s'ajoutant ou 530 déjà présents
concernés par la politique agressive de
recep tayyip erdogan en syrie
la russie souhaite également apporter
son aide à l'europe nous comprenons
pleinement la complexité du problème des
migrants pour l'union européenne je l'
ai déjà dit
un dialogue est en cours entre la
fédération de russie et la diplomatie
européenne et nous allons le poursuivre
de son côté la france par le biais du
ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian condamne fermement le
comportement de la turquie
nous avons demandé le président de la
république au président poutine de faire
cesser cette offensive d'idlib d'en
revenir aux cadres de sotchi mais la
solidarité doit aller dans les deux sens
et l' usage par la turquie des migrants
comme moyen de pression et de chantage
sur l'europe est absolument inacceptable
pendant ce temps là des dizaines de
milliers de personnes attendent toujours
de savoir leur prochaine destination et
pour une blanche maison expert en
relations internationales l'union
européenne a clairement montré sa
solidarité avec la grece aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les présidents des trois
principales institutions européennes
sont sur la frontière gréco-turque
naturellement côté grec pour manifester
la solidarité européenne avec l'état
membre qui est la grèce qui a une
frontière avec la turquie et qui est
directement menacé par l'afflux de
réfugiés venant de turquie donc ursula
von der leyen a en effet promis des
moyens elle a même annoncé 700 millions
d'euros ce qui est tout à fait
considérable s'était décidée en très peu
de temps
le président du conseil européen est
présent avec elle c'est très rare se
déplaçant même avec elle ainsi que le
président du parlement européen donc
politiquement la réponse est là l'europe
sera solidaire et je crois que
par ailleurs naturellement les moyens
financiers les moyens techniques que
seront mises en oeuvre
puisque l' agence frontex qui a démarré
très péniblement il ya 15 ans dispose
maintenant d'un certain nombre de moyens
de garde frontière et qu'ils seront
disposés et puis en plus évidemment il
est possible que tel ou tel état membre
conclu des accords bilatéraux avec la
grèce pour apporter des moyens
supplémentaires vote décisif pour les
primaires démocrates américaine 14 états
vote lors du super tuesday étape
déterminante pour départager le favori
et bernie sanders et joe biden l'ancien
vice président a le vent en poupe après
avoir rassemblé le camp modéré dans la
course à la maison blanche
derrière la lutte est intense pour
passer et les 15% et obtenir et des
supers des ligues et aux somptueuses
maintenant nous entrons dans le super
tuesday en virginie et je crois très
fermement que les gens de ce pays pour
le super tuesday et après vont soutenir
notre campagne parce que nous sommes
plus qu'une campagne
nous sommes un mouvement big ben et jen
est out
tous ces votes pour le super tuesday
iront à joe biden l'endormi excellent
timing c'est le vrai début de
l'élimination de bernis par les
démocrates
encore une fois pas de nomination si on
perd le texas nous n'aurons plus jamais
de président républicain de notre vivant
si le tarn county tombe le texas tombe
et si le texas tombe adieu donald trump
à paris également en votes lors de ce
super tuesday les précisions de notre
reporter katia technique dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris
c'est le super tuesday étape cruciale
pour les primaires démocrates américaine
14 étapes ont voté comme le colorado le
texas ou encore la californie ainsi que
les îles samoa et puis un seizième
scrutin les américains de l'étranger ici
à paris à l'est
américaine ce sont les américains de
france qui vont voter pour le premier
jour ils ont jusqu'au 10 mars
ils se sont pressés aujourd'hui dans ce
bâtiment pour désigner un candidat
démocrate
il y a encore cinq candidats en lice
deux font la course en tête tout d'abord
bernie sanders le favori des sondages le
très social qui se bat pour la sécurité
sociale il est crédité de 29%
d'intentions de vote derrière lui joe
biden l'ancien vice-président de barack
obama
c'est lui le favori du parti mais il
n'est crédité que de 17% d'intentions de
vote est encore derrière michael
vineberg avec 15% malgré des frais de
campagne est exorbitant 400 millions
juste en frais de campagne
ici donc je vous disais les électeurs
américains sont nombreux et ils veulent
absolument que berck donald trump perdre
les prochaines élections je vous propose
de les écouter
oui pour moi c'est très important de
voter pour vous êtes très important de
voter tout court mais surtout pour les
idées qu'on a déjà en france on a déjà
les choses comme la sécurité sociale on
a déjà une université qui coûte pas très
cher donc pour moi c'est très important
même si on habite à l'étranger de
l'étrangère de voter pour
pour améliorer le pays même si on n'y
habitent pas on paie toujours les impôts
en tant qu'américains donc c'est
toujours très important de le faire
partie de 2,2 tout ça et de voter
comptant peu cette élection est
tellement importante c'est des enjeux
énormes
d'habitude je vote toujours mais je suis
moins engagés et là je veux vraiment
participer je veux vraiment sentir les
autres je veux j'ai la foi je pense que
c'est 70% des américains sans pour
sécurité sociale mais on a peur de ce
mot socialiste communiste et mais c'est
vraiment pas le cas il ya beaucoup
d'américains surtout les jeunes qui
savent que en fait c'est pas très
différent ce qu'on l'a en europe et pour
eux et pour nous c'est très important de
deux de voter pour pouvoir dire que
c'est notre pays et qu'on veut ça et on
veut pas mourir parce qu'on est pauvre
où on veut avoir des aides sociales pour
robert pattison stratèges démocrates
tout reste à faire pour les candidats
démocrates encore en lice même si les
résultats de ce mardi vont être
déterminants non je il détaille ce soir
il ya encore beaucoup de délégués à la
californie à 500 délégués des états
comme la chine qui cède sa a déjà à
presque 100 délégués donc nous pourrions
voir un gagnant des primaires en
fonction de ce qui se produit ce soir
cela aurait trop tôt pour en tirer des
conclusions
surtout parce que nous avons encore diop
hayden qui est qui participent à la
course et qui va avoir de bons résultats
aussi des états unis il ya encore des
relais sand qui va être populaire en
qualifs californie ou dans le reste et
on en a aussi
l'ancien maire de new york new york qui
est milliardaire qui a défoncé dans le
monde argent dans cette campagne
donc nous ne savons pas quel effet va
avoir les millions de dollars qu'il a
défoncé pour sa course la compagnie ont
fini ce journal avec cette mobilisation
en cours dans paris une manifestation
sauvage des partisans de la manif pour
tous qui sont descendus dans les rues de
paris en fin de journée
comme vous le voyez sur ces images les
aides manifestants ont tenté de se
rapprocher du ministère de la santé
un rassemblement à l'appel du collectif
pour protester contre le projet de loi
bioéthique
une nouvelle action est prévue ce
dimanche contre la pma et la gp voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité de man à 7h heure française
passé une excellente nuit avec nous sur
rt france
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable nos soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant écoper
faire un peu plus de 5000 militaires
français à l'efficacité certes reconnu
sur une zone aussi vaste même renforcé
par cinq mille soldats pour li par les
pays vieux zinc zn c'est là où les
problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques